Es wird immer der Argument sein, dass Videogame für Spaß gespielt werden sollen. Verstehe mich, es sind einige sehr Spaß. Aber competitive Gaming, wenn du deinen Namen auf einen Weltrekord hängen willst, dann musst du den Preis bezahlen.
Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 170 und der Express rollt immer noch durch die Lande, genau genommen durch die süddeutschen Lande und mittlerweile hat es mich bis nach Karlsruhe verschlagen. Ja, um dort mal wieder ein paar andere interessante Sachen aufzunehmen. Nämlich ein Blick in die Arcade werfen, dachte ich, wäre vielleicht mal ganz angemessen und da ich ja immer keine Ahnung habe, ist gut, wenn man jemanden hat, der da mehr Einblick hat und ich begrüße Mario, Marion Berluti.
Berluti, schön, ich muss mit dem R mehr rollen.
Ja, Karlsruhe, genau genommen sitzen wir jetzt hier gerade inmitten von einer überhaupt nicht zu überblickenden Anzahl von riesigen Arcade-Automaten.
Wie viele sind's?
Also in unserer permanenten Ausstellung, die auch spielbar sind, haben wir über 60 Automaten.
Über 60?
Also, ganze Menge.
Das Ganze sind auch nicht deine, sondern das ist ein Verein, der dahinter steckt, nämlich der Retro Games e.V., der hier in Karlsruhe ein größeres Archiv solcher Computerspiele-Automaten zusammengetragen hat. Ein paar Flipper sind auch dabei.
Richtig.
Sonst noch irgendwelche Gerätetypen, die so nicht in den...
Eigentlich nicht. Also Konsolen, Homecomputer haben wir natürlich auch. Wir versuchen eigentlich das komplette Spektrum der Videospiele abzudecken, aber im Moment durch unsere begrenzten Räumlichkeiten liegt unser Fokus einfach auf den Arcade-Maschinen.
Genau, also muss man ja auch mal sagen, also Retro Games e.V. ist ein Verein, der sich der Archivierung, Konservierung, aber auch regelmäßigen B-Spielung von Computerspiele-Maschinen gewidmet hat. Kann man das so zusammenfassen?
Also unser Motto ist auch, wir sind ein Verein zur Erhaltung und Pflege der Videospielkultur. Also das Wörtchen Kultur soll bei uns eine große Rolle spielen.
Ja, das hoffe ich, denn bei CRE spielt das ja auch mal eine große Rolle. Ja, deswegen wollen wir auch darüber reden. Also die Arcade, da muss man ganz schön weit zurückblättern. Also das ist ja so ein etablierter Begriff mittlerweile, wo zumindest die meisten Leute, glaube ich, sofort an eben genau an das denken. Computer-Spiele und das ist irgendwie die Arcade. Aber eigentlich war die Arcade ja mal eine, genau das nämlich, so eine Arcade, also so wie man das so kennt. So ein Gebäude hängt so ein bisschen über mit Säulen und dahinter sind halt so Läden.
Genau.
Wann hatte das überhaupt, das geht ja weit, weit, weit, weit, weit zurück?
Ja, das war eigentlich schon so in den 50er, 60er Jahren, als es nur mechanische Spielautomaten gab. Und diese mechanischen Spielautomaten, die waren schon in Spielhallen gebündelt und das waren dann die sogenannten Penny-Arcades. Also Penny, weil die Automaten mit einem Penny funktioniert haben und Arcade, weil die Gebäude, in denen die Arcades standen, halt diese Arcadenform hatten.
Da hat sich quasi eingebürgert, dass man sozusagen diese Spielgeräte, diese geldbetriebenen Spielgeräte einfach so vorgehalten werden und dann geht man da so hin, dann geht man in die Arcade und dann kann man da seine Pennies loswerden. Und ja, also mechanisch heißt, das war ja, da kommt ja auch der Pinball her, ein Flipper, was ja genau genommen mal nichts anderes war als ein Holzbrett mit Nägeln.
Genau, deshalb auch der Name Pinball.
Genau, das weiß auch nicht jeder. Wo man dann im Wesentlichen, ich weiß nicht, wie hat man das bedient, da war schon dieses Ding, man schießt die Kugel hoch und dann fällt die so von oben durch diese Nagelteile nach unten und dann war es, glaube ich, eher so eine Glückssache, wo er dann ankam.
Man konnte da eigentlich nicht viel steuern.
Also es gab keine Flipper oder so.
Die ersten Pinballs waren einfach einfache Holzbretter.
Und im Prinzip Glücksspielautomaten.
Viele Nägel waren reine Glücksspielautomaten, genau.
In Japan ist das ja immer noch...
Das sind es die Pachinkos, genau.
Ich war mal in so einem Pachinko-Laden. Alter, Falter. Also, hast du das mal gemacht?
Nein, leider noch nicht. Ich würde auch immer nach Japan fahren.
Da herrscht ein Lärm in einem industriellen Maßstab. Das ist unfassbar. Diese Türen öffnen sich, man kommt da rein. Es ist einfach nur noch ein einziges Geschepper und Geschnarre und Geklingel und Getröte. Unfassbar laut.
Und die Leute wollen sich dort erholen.
Und die Leute erholen sich da. Es ist wirklich unglaublich, von ihrem harten Alltag. Und sitzen dann vor diesen Maschinen. Und ich glaube, der Clou ist, dass man so zwei Drehknöpfe hat oder auch nur einen, ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau. Einer sogar nur, mit dem man in irgendeiner Form justiert, wie diese Kugeln da so durchfallen. Und alle sitzen irgendwie mit so Eimern, mit Metallkugeln. Die sie dann da oben reingießen. Das erschließt sich, sagen wir mal, jetzt dem Westkulturler nicht so recht ohne Weiteres.
Das ist ja auch eine Kultur, die gepflegt werden muss.
Aber dafür seid ihr nicht zuständig?
Leider nicht, nein. Wird uns aber auch mal interessieren, so einen Pacinko-Automaten im Verein zu haben.
Zurück zur Arcade. Das heißt, die Arcade hat sich eigentlich in dem Moment noch mal neu erfunden, in dem Moment, wo Strom dazukam.
Richtig, wo die Elektrik dann dazukam, oder das Elektronische. Da muss man eigentlich ein bisschen weiter zurückschauen. Der Anfang der Videospiele war ja eigentlich schon in den 50er-, 60er-Jahren, oder zumindest das, was man für ein Videospiel halten konnte. Die echten elektronischen Arcade-Automaten, die kamen dann aber tatsächlich erst in den 70er-Jahren, also Anfang der 70er-Jahre aufs Programm. Aber die haben auch ihren Ursprung an so alten Projekten, das waren ja damals alles Projekte an Universitäten oder an Laboren, wie zum Beispiel der Tennis 4.2 von 1958, das wurde an der Brookhaven National Laboratory in New York entwickelt. Das gilt so im Allgemeinen als das erste elektronische Videospiel überhaupt. Die Experten streiten sich dann auch ein bisschen darüber. Es gibt noch so einen Vorgänger, der nennt sich Oxo, das ist so ein Tic-Tac-Tos-Spiel. Das war schon 1952. Oxo? Oxo, genau.
O-X-O?
Genau, der Name kommt aus diesem O-X-O. Denn wenn man Tic-Tac-Tos spielt, dann zeichnet man entweder ein Kreis oder ein X. Und daher kommt der Name Teehee. Und dieses Oxo, das lief noch auf so einem riesigen Analogrechner und hatte dann einfach so eine reine Lichtanzeige, Diodenanzeige. Damals waren es noch keine Dioden, da waren es einfach Lämpchen. Und die hatten dann so eine, ich glaube, es war 13 mal 30 Matrix oder so, in der das Spielfeld dann vom Tic-Tac-Toe angezeigt wurde. Aber es war halt noch kein richtig bewegliches Spiel wie damals Tennis for Two, was in Brookhaven entwickelt wurde.
Aber aus 1952?
Richtig, ja. Das erste, was man eher mit einem modernen Videospiel in Verbindung bringt, ist wirklich dieses Tennis for Two, was 1958 entwickelt wurde, von William Higginbotham. Das war also im Prinzip das erste Tennisspiel überhaupt. Also nicht so wie das Pong, was man heutzutage kennt, wo man das Spielfeld im Prinzip von oben sieht, sondern man stand in Prinzip seitlich am Spielfeldrand, so auf Netzhöhe. Und das Ganze lief auf einem Oszilloskopen, das lief nicht auf einem Fernseher. Und ein Oszilloskop ist ja so ein elektronisches Messgerät. Damit wird ja die Spannung gemessen, also in ihrem Zeitverlauf. Das heißt, man hat auch eine begrenzte Anzeige. Also die Horizontale auf dem Oszilloskopen, die den Zeitverlauf darstellt, die war im Prinzip das Spielfeld. In der Mitte war noch ein kleiner Punkt, der das Netz simulieren sollte. Und dann der Spielball war im Prinzip die Spannungsanzeige, die dann in ihrer Wellenform über den Oszilloskopen glitt. Und die Spieler hatten dann die Möglichkeit, den Spielball im Abschlagswinkel zu beeinflussen.
Und wie hat man den beeinflusst? Was war sozusagen der Joystick?
Ja, das war dann ein ganz normales Kästchen mit Drehreglern drauf.
Also den Joystick haben sie sozusagen gleich noch dazu erfunden?
Ja, mehr oder weniger. Also es war kein Stab, sondern es war halt so ein Drehregler.
Sozusagen einfach nur so ein Putti und dann haben wir da so dann rumgedreht. Richtig.
Aha.
Und schon war da irgendwie das elektronische Spiel geboren?
Ja, mehr oder weniger. Und die Leute, also beitagte offenen Tür oder so an diesem Labor standen die Leute echt Schlange, um dieses Spiel zu spielen. Kann ich mir vorstellen, ich meine 1958. 1958.
Wenn ich mir noch überlege, was die Leute noch in den 80er Jahren über Computer gestaunt haben, kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, was 1958 das bedeutet haben mag.
Das ist mir ja auch, als ich an meinem ersten Arcade-Automaten stand. Das war ja für mich auch schon faszinierend. Das war 1978, 1979. Da liegen ja Jahre dazwischen.
Aber so richtig, was man jetzt unter Computerspiel versteht, waren diese Installationen natürlich auch noch nicht.
Nein, das waren wie gesagt alles so Labor- und Universitätsprojekte, um einfach mal zu zeigen, wie leistungsfähig Computer sind. Man wollte da wirklich das Maximum herauskitzeln. Genauso auch 1962 am MIT, am Massachusetts Institute of Technology. Da entwickelte Steve Russell mit ein paar Kollegen das Space War. Das war 1962 und das Space War würde ich schon eher als das erste richtige Computerspiel bezeichnen. Das hat so ganz typische Elemente, die man auch in den ersten Arcade-Automaten wiedergefunden hat. Zum einen war das Thema Weltraum. Das war ein Weltraum-Shooter. Man musste versuchen, sich da gegenseitig abzugnallen mit seinen Raumschiffen. Es war auch das erste Multiplayer-Spiel. Man konnte also erst gegeneinander spielen.
Wieso aber Tennis war doch auch Fortwo?
Tennis war auch Fortwo, ja. Ich persönlich sehe Tennis Fortwo nicht als das erste Videospiel an. Obwohl es von der Definition hier eigentlich schon das erste Videospiel ist. Aber wie gesagt, im Bezug auf die Arcade-Automaten gesehen, ist für mich eigentlich Spacewar der eigentliche Beginn.
Spacewar, ja. Spacewar, das war ja auch die, das war ja im Prinzip auch genau diese Gruppe am MIT, die ja so ein bisschen auch so die Ursuppe dieses Hackertums mitbestimmt hat, weil die ja da auch erst mal diesen Begriff überhaupt erfunden haben, hacken.
Genau.
Tech Model Railroad Club, wo sie dann irgendwie sich sozusagen um die Unterseite ihres Eisenbahnmodells gekümmert haben. Die Jungs, die da immer so die Kabel zusammengedrinkt haben und dann haben sie halt irgendwann diesen Computer in die Hände bekommen, der da gerade mal nicht benutzt wurde und da...
Das war die PDB-1 vom Deck.
Genau, und da sind sie dann eben, ja, dann haben sie sozusagen, was machen wir jetzt damit? Dann haben sie dieses Computerspiel erfunden. Also es mag nicht der allererste Schritt gewesen sein, aber das war sozusagen eine der Maßnahmen, die sie dann ergriffen haben, nachdem sie diesen Computer überhaupt erst mal unter ihren Fittichen hatten. Das war im Prinzip auch die erste interaktive Programmierung, die jetzt so ein Home-Use auch zum Hintergrund hatte, während die Rechner ja ansonsten extrem selten waren. Wir reden hier immer noch über...
62.
The early days. Ja, und dann ist es auch interessant, dass eben eine der ersten Sachen, die einfach da rauskommt, wenn sich Leute einfach interaktiv mit so einem Computer beschäftigen, ist, dass man ein Spiel schreibt. Das sagt ja eigentlich auch schon eine Menge aus.
Das finde ich auch eigentlich witzig. Man wollte ja wirklich zeigen, wie leistungsfähig ist jetzt diese PDB-1. Und man hat da nicht irgendwie versucht, irgendwelche Sternen-Konstellationen oder was ähnliches auszurechnen, sondern man hat ein Spiel programmiert. Man hat einfach ein Spiel programmiert. Das sieht man ja auch noch heute. Die ganze Computertechnik, vor allen Dingen Homecomputer und PC, die wären sicherlich nicht so weit, wenn nicht die Spieleentwicklung gewesen wäre. Ich finde, Spiele sind ein unwahrscheinlicher Motivationsfaktor gewesen für die Entwicklung der Technik und für den PC. Allein was Grafikkarten und so weiter angeht.
Weil das ja auch Kaufnachfrage erzeugt hat, weil das ja auch etwas war, was die Leute auch machen wollten.
Das gehört ja auch immer dazu, um etwas zu verkaufen.
Spacewar, damit war sozusagen ein Dammbruch erreicht. Aber so eine Spieleindustrie, da musste man doch schon noch ein paar Jahre warten, Anfang der 60er Jahre. Wann musste man jetzt wahrscheinlich nochmal einen Bereich überbrücken, bis wirklich die Homecomputer auch dazukamen?
Das war schon ein bisschen früher. Die Homecomputer kamen ja so 1977, 1978 dann so letztendlich auf die Bildfläche. Die Arcade-Automaten, also auch der erste Arcade-Automat, der kam dann schon ein bisschen früher, der erblickte das Licht der Welt 1971. Aber auch fast zehn Jahre nach Spacewar.
Und das war?
Also diese Zeit war ja noch geprägt durch Pinballs. Der erste Arcade-Automat ist Computerspace von Nothing Association.
Computerspace?
Genau, Computerspace.
Das bezieht sich auch schon jetzt auf den Weltraum-Space?
Ja, das Spiel ist sehr angelehnt eigentlich an Spacewar. Also da geht es auch darum, also Weltraum-Genre, man hat ein Ufo und man muss versuchen, man hat ein Raumschiff, meine ich, und man muss versuchen, zwei andere UFOs damit abzuschießen. Der Computer-Space war auch der erste Automat, der so diese typische Grundform eines Arcade-Automaten geprägt hat. Also wir haben ja auch noch gar nicht darüber gesprochen, was macht einen Arcade-Automaten eigentlich aus? Man versteht eigentlich unter einem Arcade-Automaten ein Gehäuse, das etwa die Form und die Größe eines Standkühlschranks hat, in der Regel aus Holz, aber auch aus anderen Materialien kann der gebaut sein, aus Fiberglas, Kunststoff. Und genau dieser Computer-Space-Automat hat auch die Grundform vorgelegt. Das heißt, oben haben wir ein Monitor, in der Mitte etwa das Control-Panel und unten befindet sich dann der Geldeinwurf. Bei den Arcade-Automaten ist es auch so, die ersten Arcade-Automaten waren relativ schlicht. Nachdem man aber gemerkt hat, man kann damit auch Geld machen, es ist wichtig, die Arcade-Automaten auch gut zu präsentieren, wurden natürlich die Gehäuse entsprechend bemalt oder beklebt und bedruckt.
Um Aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen?
Genau, um Aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen. Und genau diese Grafiken auf der Seite, also z.B. auf der Seite eines Automaten, die bezeichnet man als Side Art in einem Automaten. Die Umrandung um den Bildschirm an sich, der auch immer grafisch ausgeschmückt ist, das ist sogenannte Biselle, das Control Panel, auf den der Joystick und die Buttons angebracht waren, das ist das Control Panel. Und oben auf der Kopfhöhe des Spielers haben wir das sogenannte Marquee, also quasi die Marquise, die oft beleuchtet ist. In der der Automaten-Name steht, die oft beleuchtet ist.
Oder die Firma, die es gebaut hat.
Oder die unter uns nennen auch. Oder es steht dann mit dabei. In kleinen Buchstaben, genau.
Na ja, da haben sie auch relativ schnell starke Marken herausgebildet, oder?
Ja, richtig. Also, Nothing Associates.
Die kennen ja wirklich keinen Menschen mehr.
Ja, die kennen wirklich wenige. Das war Bill Nothing, der die Firma gegründet hat. Der Programmierer von Computerspace war kein Geringerer als Nolan Bashnell. Den kennen ja viele als den Gründer von Atari. Ein Jahr später, 1972, wurde Atari gegründet. Das erste Projekt, das Nolan Bashnell durchgeführt hat, war die Programmierung von Computerspace.
Und dann hat er gemerkt, das kann ja richtig funktionieren.
Genau, da hat er gemerkt, das funktioniert. Bei Computerspace war wirtschaftlich gesehen kein großer Erfolg. Das Spiel war auch einfach zu komplex, auch für die damalige Zeit. Die Leute, die spielten ja an Pinballs. Das waren ja relativ einfache Geräte. Man hatte ja einfach zwei Buttons, wo man den rechten und den linken Schläger des Flippers bewegen konnte. Und der Spacewar-Automat, dazu muss man sagen... Ja, Computer Space natürlich. Das Raumschiff steuerte man rein mit Buttons. Man muss sich das so vorstellen, als wäre das Raumschiff mit einer Nadel wie ein Sekundenzeiger fixiert. Man hatte zwei Knöpfe, wo man den Kopf des Raumschiffs nach rechts oder nach links neigen konnte. Mit zwei Köpfen neigte man den Kopf des Raumschiffs nach rechts oder nach links. Mit einem weiteren Knopf konnte man das Raumschiff beschleunigen. Aus dieser Kombination der drei Knöpfe heraus musste man das Raumschiff steuern. Das war schon eine relativ komplexe Steuerung im Vergleich zu einem einfachen Joystick.
Das Raumschiff war dann immer in der Mitte?
Das Raumschiff befand sich immer unten. Dann konnte man es mit diesen drei Knöpfen durch den Raum bewegen. Das hat die Leute damals eigentlich überfordert. Deshalb war es auch kein großer wirtschaftlicher...
Das ist aber die gleiche Steuerung, wie sie sich später auch bei Asteroids durchgesetzt hat, oder?
Genau, das ist es nämlich. Das Witzige daran ist, dass später genau diese Steuerung ein riesengroßer Erfolg, also 1979 war das dann, bei Asteroids wurde. Aber die Zeit war halt noch nicht reif für diese komplexe Steuerung und für dieses komplexe Spiel. Und deshalb musste ein anderes Spiel kommen, was dann auch tatsächlich den Durchbruch schaffte. Das war dann Pong. Und viele wissen von uns vielleicht, Pong ist ja ein Produkt von Atari. Und ich hatte es ja auch schon angesprochen, der Nolan Baschnell, der das Computer Space entwickelt hat, ist ja der Gründer von Atari. Der hat sich dann danach gedacht, ne, ich mach da was Eigenes. Und seine Idee, seine geklaute Idee oder geliehene Idee, war dann Pong. Eigentlich war das ja dann Tennis for Two sozusagen. Eigentlich nicht, eigentlich nicht. Denn Tennis for Two war ja ein Spiel von der Seitenansicht. Also man sah ja den Tennis-Court von der Seite, also auf Netzhöhe. Und Pong sieht man ja von oben, also schon ein anderes Spiel passiert.
Okay, aber das Tennis da funktionieren kann, das war schon irgendwie so ein bisschen mit drin.
Aber die eigentliche Idee, die hatte Ralf Beer. Und Ralf Beer ist ja der Erfinder der Spielekonsole schlechthin. Also der hatte 1968 schon die Idee dafür. Also für das Grundspiel, für dieses Ping-Pong, wie er es damals nannte.
Klingt der jetzt nur deutsch oder kommt der aus Deutschland?
Der kommt ursprünglich aus Deutschland, ja. Er ist ein Emigrant. Und das wurde damals entwickelt, ein großer Begriff ist auch die sogenannte Brown Box. Das war der erste Prototyp dieses Ping-Pong-Automaten. Und 1971 gab es dann Beziehungen zu der Firma Magnavox. Und man versuchte das Ganze dann für den Markt reif zu machen. Und die erste Konsole, die dann erschien, die hieß Magnavox Odyssey. Und Ralph Baer war im Prinzip der Erfinder des Spiels Ping-Pong. Witzige daran, Nolan Bashnell hatte auf einer Messe, auf der dieses Ping-Pong, auf der Magnavox Odyssey vorgestellt wurde, 1971 zum ersten Mal dieses Produkt gesehen. Und hat sich gedacht, geniales Spiel, geniale Idee, das versuche ich in einen Arcade-Automaten umzusetzen.
Also war auch nicht das einzige Spiel auf dieser Konsole.
Richtig, also diese Konsole war schon so designt, dass sie auch mehrere Spiele ausführen konnte. Und bei einem Arcade-Automaten ist es ja so, ein Arcade-Automat stellt in der Regel immer nur ein Spiel.
Table Tennis war das dann auf dem Magnavox. Und das hat er sich angeschaut und hat sich gedacht, prima, das klaue ich mal.
Das ist eine super Idee. Ich nenne das dann einfach mal Pong. Und versuche das dann in einen Arcade-Automaten zu packen. Er selber hat es dann damals nicht programmiert. Das war Alan Alcorn, der das Ganze dann programmiert hat.
Das heißt, zu dem Zeitpunkt hat er sich schon quasi so als Firmenmensch neu positioniert.
Und Atari ist eigentlich auch eine der Firmen, die in der ganzen Arcade-Geschichte schon eine zentrale Rolle spielt. Also wenn wir jetzt noch ein bisschen länger drüberplaudern, dann wird der Name Atari noch öfters fallen. Also es sind nicht nur die ersten gewesen oder eine der ersten gewesen, sondern...
Aber wie erfolgreich war denn Pong? Also ich meine, was ist denn dann passiert?
Pong war eigentlich extrem erfolgreich. Noel Baschnell hatte einen Kumpel, der eine Bar hatte. Und in der Bar stellte er den Automaten zum ersten Mal aus, um zu gucken, wie die Leute darauf reagieren. Und nach einem Abend war der Geldspeicher eigentlich voll vom Automaten. Und daran erkannten die, dass es ein Erfolg war.
Und dann hat sich das, wie weit verbreitet, stand ja schon überall dann? Oder was war das dann? Also ich meine, wie groß war das? Es hat sicherlich mehr als nur eine Bar funktioniert. Die Frage ist, in wie viele Bars kam das? Also wie weit hat sich das dann eigentlich, hast du eine Vorstellung davon?
Nicht konkret, aber es ging über ganz Amerika. Was auch witzig ist, der Name Atari, den verbinden ja viele eigentlich mit einer japanischen Firma. Vor allen Dingen, weil das Zeichen von Atari diese drei geschwungenen Linien sind. Viele dachten auch, das wäre der Berg Fujiyama. Und verbinden deshalb Atari auch immer mit einer japanischen Firma. Aber Atari ist eine rein amerikanische Firma. Und es ist auch ganz witzig, Nolan Baschnell wollte die Firma eigentlich Sissy G nennen am Anfang. Das ist so ein Begriff, der eine Planetenkonstellation beschreibt. Und musste dann aber feststellen, dass der Name schon vergeben war. Und entschloss sich dann, die Firma so zu nennen, wie ein Begriff aus seinem Lieblingsspiel, aus dem japanischen Spiel Go. Und deshalb kommt auch der Name Atari her.
Was ist Atari im Go?
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Ich frage mal die Müllhalter. Eine Stellung im Brettspiel Go.
Atari bezeichnet im japanischen Brettspiel Go die Stellung, in der Steine geschlagen werden können. Wie passend.
Und das tat er dann auch. Ja, Treffer versenkt ist gut. Er bekam dann einen Schuss vorm Bug. Denn Ralf Beer ließ es nicht auf sich sitzen, sondern dachte sich, die Idee ist doch von mir geklaut. Beziehungsweise Magnavox, die ja die Odyssey-Konsole herstellten, die verklagten dann daraufhin Atari. Das kam dann zu einem Vergleich. Atari musste 700.000 Dollar zahlen an Magnavox und Ralf Beer. Bekam aber dann die Rechte für Pong zugesprochen. Das war natürlich im Nachhinein ein günstiger Kauf. Denn Pong war über Jahre hin ein Erfolg. Wenn man das vergleicht mit der heutigen Spieleindustrie, da kommt ein Spiel raus, das sieht man dann ein halbes Jahr oder so auf der Spielfläche, maximal vielleicht ein Jahr. In einem Jahr erscheinen ja heute hunderte von Spielen. Früher war es ja so, dass Pong bis in die 80er hinein ein bekanntes Spiel war. Gerade auf Home-Spielkonsolen. Da gab es über diesen Zeitraum von acht, neun Jahren nichts anderes als Pong oder Pongähnliches.
Als Computerspielkonsole auf der Atari 2600 wahrscheinlich noch erfolgreicher als die Arcade-Automaten. Richtig, richtig. Aber es müsste ja auch schnell anderen aufgefallen sein, dass generell dieses Prinzip der Konsole, also der das Arcade-Automaten, anschlägt. Zu Hause hatte man ja nicht den Fernseher schon in der gleichen Verbreitung, etc. Die Infrastruktur, die man heutzutage als gegeben voraussetzt, die war ja damals noch weitgehend abwesend. Es gab natürlich gerade in den USA schon mehrere Haushalte, die jetzt einen Fernseher hatten. Aber nicht wahr? Das war noch nicht usus, dass man da überhaupt eine Antenne anschließen konnte, wo man ein Signal einspeisen konnte.
Genau, gerade die Odyssey von Ralf Beer, die war in den Staaten vor allen Dingen ein Erfolg Anfang der 70er Jahre. Aber ein begrenzter Erfolg, denn es war einfach eine teure Konsole. Und die wenigsten konnten sich so ein Gimmick damals leisten. Das war einfach zu teuer. Und das war auch der Grund, warum sich auch diese Arcade-Kultur gebildet hat. Denn Arcade-Automaten, auch von ihrer Technik her, die waren teuer. Und die konnte sich natürlich nicht jeder leisten. Und deshalb musste man einen Weg finden, damit jeder an den Automaten spielen konnte. Und dann hat man halt auf die Arcade gesetzt, dass man gesagt hat, man nimmt jetzt einen Automaten, stellt ihn irgendwo hin und verlangt halt dann Geld dafür, damit die Leute daran spielen.
Wie früher mit den Pinballs.
Wie früher mit den Pinballs, richtig. Und mit Pong waren die Leute angefixt. Und dann ging die ganze Geschichte weiter.
Und wie ging es dann weiter? Wer kam denn nach?
Also Atari hat viele Automaten dann in der Zeit produziert. Es gab dann so einen Doppelpong oder einen Quadrapong, wo dann mehrere spielen konnten. Die meisten anderen Arcade-Firmen, die stellten auch Pong-Klone her, an denen Atari auch viel Lizenzgebühren verdiente, beziehungsweise es gab dann die eine oder andere Klage gegen andere Firmen. Und Atari war da relativ dick im Geschäft Anfang der 70er Jahre. Da kamen dann auch noch so Automaten wie Grand Track 10. Das war einer der ersten Rennautomaten. Das war die Rennstrecke. Man sah dann die Rennstrecke in Draufsicht. Die Autos waren einfach mit ein paar kleinen Strichen dargestellt. Man konnte aber mit einem echten Lenkrad am Automaten die Fahrzeuge bewegen. Das ist auch das Faszinierende, wie ich finde, an so Arcade-Automaten. Man hat nicht einfach einen nichtssagenden Controller in der Hand, sondern man hat etwas Richtiges in der Hand, das einen mit dem Automaten verbindet. Das ist auch die Stärke, die ein Arcade-Automaten jeder Spielekonsole gegenüber hat. Ein Arcade-Automat fokussiert sich auf ein Game, auf ein Thema. Das komplette Gehäuse fokussiert sich auf dieses Thema, der Automat an sich und natürlich auch die Steuereinheit. Ob das jetzt ein Periskop bei einem U-Boot-Automaten ist oder das Lenkrad bei einem Rennautomaten. Das schafft auch irgendwie einen ganz anderen Bezug als Spieler zu dem Automaten. Auch wenn die Technik sehr einfach und simpel gehalten ist, hat man einen viel engeren Bezug zum Spiel durch diese besonderen Controller. Und das zeigte eigentlich auch schon eines der ersten Rennspieler, also dieses Grand Track 10.
Was dann sozusagen auch ein bisschen der Begründer war von den Renngames.
Richtig, ja.
Aber bestimmte Genres haben sich ja über die Zeit schon ziemlich festgebissen. Ich witzel mal ganz gerne so, dass es ja eh nur so drei oder vier Spiele gibt. Welche sind es? Da, wo man alle erschießen muss. Das mit dem Auto. Da, wo man die Prinzessin fangen muss. Und jetzt hab ich noch eins vergessen.
Ja, aber da hat es noch lange gedauert zum Beispiel, bis man die Prinzessin fangen musste. Das war dann eigentlich erst so das erste Spiel mit...
Am Anfang war erst mal so das mit dem Ball.
Richtig.
Das hab ich vergessen.
Also es waren Sportspiele und eigentlich schon Schießspiele. Und auch witzig, der Zeitgeist beeinflusste auch immer die Spiele. Warum waren die ersten Spiele unbedingt Weltraum-Shooter? Ich meine, die 60er Jahre mit Mondlandung und Science-Fiction, die waren einfach geprägt. Und auch dann die 70er Jahre.
In der Hollywood-Kultur, also in der Filmkultur, hat sich das ja im Prinzip genauso niedergeschlagen.
Genau, ob das jetzt Star Trek ist oder ob das jetzt Star Wars war, was dann in den Ende der 70er kam. Das sind alles so Filme gewesen, die die Spiele dann unmittelbar beeinflusst haben.
Oder Forbidden Planet.
Da, wo sich Star Trek alles abgeguckt hat.
Ich kenne die wenigsten.
Ich kenne die wenigsten leider. Muss man sich mal anschauen, da fällt man tot um, wenn man Forbidden Planet gesehen hat und dann Star Trek schon kennt. Dann fragt man sich wirklich, was eigentlich Star Trek noch Neues erwunden hat. Aber so richtig los ging es Ende der 70er, kann man sagen.
Ja, so einen richtigen Knall hat es eigentlich gemacht mit Space Invaders. Das war dann 1978. Und Space Invaders war der Knaller schlechthin. Der hat auch dann die ganze Industrie richtig zum Rollen gebracht. Und man spricht auch da von der goldenen Ära der Videospiele oder der Golden Age of the Arcades, die dann 1978 mit Space Invaders begonnen hat und dann so 1982, 1983 zu Ende war.
Aber das waren jetzt auch schon die Japaner?
Und witzigerweise, die meisten Arcade-Spiele haben auch Amerikaner entwickelt. Also wie bei den Spielen heutzutage gibt es Entwickler und es gibt Publisher der Spiele. Also es gibt Leute, die das Spiel tatsächlich entwickeln und andere, die es verbreiten. Und bei den Arcade-Automaten war es nicht anders. Es gab auch reine Spieleentwicklerfirmen, die dann ihre Spiele dann an Publisher verkauft haben. Wie zum Beispiel bei Space Invaders war der Entwickler Taito, also die japanische Firma Taito. Aber der Publisher dann in Amerika war mit Way.
Die natürlich Vertriebsnetz hatten etc. Das spielt ja auch eine Rolle.
Und die auch schon vorher eigene Automaten, also in Amerika, vertrieben hatten. Das ist auch ganz interessant. Da müssen wir vielleicht noch mal einen Schritt zurückspringen in das Jahr 1975 zum Automaten Gunfight. Den hat nämlich Taito auch entwickelt. Und das ist der erste Automat, der dann tatsächlich einen Mikroprozessor hat. Also alle Automaten von 1965, die hatten einfache TTL-Technik. Also TTLs, das sind Transistor-Logik-Bausteine. Also einfache integrierte Schaltkreise. Mit denen man natürlich auch eine Art Computer oder ein Art Prozessor designen kann. Aber der echte erste Mikroprozessor in einem Automaten war da 1975 in Gunfight. Wobei Gunfight ursprünglich von Taito noch als TTL-Board entwickelt wurde. Aber als Midway dann die Rechte an Gunfight kaufte, wurde das dann von Dave Nutting umgerüstet zu einem Mikroprozessor-Game. Und den Namen Nutting, den haben wir ja schon mal gehört bei Nothing Associates. Das war aber der Bill Nutting, also ein Bruder, der diese Nutting Associates-Firma gegründet hatte. Und der andere Bruder, der Dave, der hat dann dieses Gunfight-Modul oder diese Gunfight-Plattine in eine Mikroprozessor-Plattine umgerüstet. Das war dann auch der Intel 8080. Also das waren in erster Linie 8-Bit-Prozessoren, die auch in den Arcade-Automaten zu tun sind.
Ja, der 8080 hat ja im Prinzip damals, also genau genommen gab es glaube ich vorher noch den 4004, aber der 8080, das war eigentlich so der erste wirklich erfolgreiche Mikroprozessor von Intel.
Richtig.
Und da ging das ja dann auch los, was dann sozusagen mittelfristig hin zum PC geführt hat.
Und wir sehen mal wieder, Spiele waren da auch wieder im Fokus.
Und Spiele waren da auch im Fokus. Aber jetzt ist vor allem technologisch sehr interessant, weil wie du schon sagst, vorher war sozusagen, wenn man sich, muss man sich mal klarmachen, also wenn man sozusagen so ein Computerspiel machen wollte, wie Pong, wie die anderen, dann muss man in der Lage sein einen Computer zu bauen, der eben genau das tut. Also man musste sich seine eigene Logik richtig in Hardware so zusammenstecken, dass man eben einfach für die jeweiligen benötigten Anforderungen die richtigen logischen Schritte eben durchführen konnte und das alles den Zustand wegspeichern konnte, etc., Und mit dem Mikroprozessor war es dann erstmalig möglich, das weiter zu abstrahieren und dann eben auch auf generischere Hardware aufzusetzen. Und das hat dann vermutlich auch gerade diesem Game-Bereich einen extremen Schub gegeben.
Richtig, ja.
Das ist ganz witzig, weil du gerade ansprichst, man kann ja auch mit einfachem Baustein, sag ich mal, Computerprozessoren nachbilden, also auch mit einfachen TTL-Bausteinen. Und das hat zum Beispiel eine Firma gemacht, die heißt Cinematronics. Die hat in ihren Geräten mit einfachen TTL-Bausteinen eine 12-Bit-CPU nachgebaut, also es war kein richtiger Mikroprozessor, der in den Maschinen verbaut war, wie zum Beispiel Prozessoren von Intel oder von Zilog oder von Motorola, sondern die haben mit TTL-Baustein ein 12-Bit, das ist echt eine schräge Zahl, eine 12-Bit-CPU nachgebaut.
Aber wahrscheinlich immer, was weiß ich, viel mit Instruktionen und Einbeizwege.
Man hat halt einen geringeren Adressraum.
Aber es gab auch nicht so viel Speicher zum Adressieren damals. Du hast wahrscheinlich locker ausgereicht.
Space War zum Beispiel, weil du das gerade ansprichst, Adressieren, das war ein 9K. Ja gut, das lief ja auf einer PDB-1, aber...
Ja, das macht man sich auch nicht klar, wie klein diese Programme eigentlich waren. Wir reden hier von der 8-Bit-Zeit. Damals waren vielleicht so ein Kilo, zwei Kilo, vier Kilo in dem Bereich. Da waren später auch noch Homecomputer ausgestattet, so ein ZX81, den man sich Anfang der 80er Jahre kaufen konnte. Der kam halt serienmäßig mit einem Kilobyte-Speicher.
Und der kam mit einem Z80-Prozessor von der Firma Zilog. Und genau dieser Z80-Prozessor ist ja nichts anderes als ein abwärtskompatibler Chip zum Intel 8080. Also der Zilog baut also im Prinzip auf dem 8080 von Intel auf. Und die Firma Zilog hat den entsprechend noch erweitert. Aber genau diese 8-Bit-Chips, also nur 8-Bit-Chips, die haben ganz lange bei den Arcade-Automaten so eine große Rolle gespielt. Also die meisten Automaten, auch der goldenen Ära, die funktionieren mit einem Zilog-Z80-Chip. Also das ist der Chip überhaupt. Das ist auch der Chip, der dann später in einem Sinclair-Spektrum oder so, was du angesprochen hast, oder ZX81 vorkam oder einem Schneider CPC oder so.
Genau, auch die ganze CPM-Serie damals, CPM-Betriebssystem, das war ja alles für den Z80 ausgelegt.
Exakt, ja.
Damals waren Betriebssysteme noch für Prozessoren ausgelegt.
Und den Zilog, also diesen Z80-Prozessor, den kann man ja bis heute noch kaufen. Also er wird ja bis heute noch produziert.
Ja, es ist nur noch ein universelles Teil. Es gibt ja auch genug Geräte, wo man immer mal wieder einen neuen reinschrauben muss, wenn der alte durchgebrannt ist. Ja, es ist erstaunlich, wie lange sich Technologie in dem Bereich hält, obwohl sie eigentlich immer den Ruf genießt, am laufenden Meter immer wieder alles abzustoßen. Ja, zurück zu den Arcade-Maschinen. Space Invaders hast du genannt, eigentlich, als du dann noch mal kurz zum Gunfight zurückmarschiert bist. Das heißt, Gunfight war sozusagen das erste Ding von Taito, aber erfolgreich war und wurde auch schon von Midway Games vertrieben, wie dann später auch Space Invaders. Aber Space Invaders hat irgendwie den Nerv getroffen.
Richtig, den Zeitgeist vor allen Dingen. Wann kam der erste Star Wars? Das war ja auch 78, 79. Mir ging es ja persönlich auch so. Ich habe dann im Alter von zehn Jahren den ersten Star Wars-Teil gesehen. Als zehnjähriger oder elfjähriger war ich damals, da bist du ja geflasht. Da geht man nicht ohne Schaden aus dem Team. Ich finde es auch so schade, dass George Lucas die ganzen Teile so aufbereitet hat, dass man keinen natürlichen reinen Star Wars ersten Teil mehr sehen kann. Dass da so viel CGI noch mit einfließt.
Es kommt noch schlimmer, ich glaube, jetzt wird das noch alles in 3D machen. Als ich das gehört habe, habe ich gedacht, nein, George, komm mal klar.
Genau, und unter diesem Einfluss kam dann Space Invaders, ja? Ich weiß noch, Space Invaders ist auch für mich irgendwie noch der Automat. Allein durch den Sound, den du jetzt gerade machst. So ein extrem einfacher Sound, aber der brennt sich in deinem Hirn fest und du kommst einfach davon nicht mehr los.
Auch so die Optik, nicht wahr? Also gerade in den letzten Jahren hat Space Invaders ja nochmal den mega Retro-Retro-Retro-Super-Effekt gehabt. Also allein diese ikonische Optik, welche Zeile ist nochmal der populärste? Der ganz unten oder der drüber? Ich weiß das gar nicht mehr, aber man sieht es einfach sofort. Fünf verschiedene?
Ich bin jetzt auch überfragt, aber die sehen alle gut aus.
Jeder kennt sie, jeder erkennt sie und sie stehen halt einfach ganz klar und deutlich eben für dieses Spiel und dieses Spiel steht einfach auch eindeutig für diese ganze 8-Bits-Zeit.
Die Grafiken an sich nehmen ja viele wahr als der Ursprung der Computerspiele. Es war aber der Ursprung auch der Arcades.
Und Space Invaders war dann nochmal richtig erfolgreich.
Space Invaders war mega erfolgreich. Es war sogar so erfolgreich, gerade in Japan, dass es da eine 100-Yen-Münzen-Knappheit gab. Also die Automaten funktionierten mit 100-Yen-Münzen und das hat wirklich wirtschaftliche Auswirkungen auf Japan gehabt, weil die 100-Yen-Münzen dann 1978 knapp wurden. Hammer. Und Space Invaders war ja noch schwarz-weiß, wie alle anderen Spiele davor auch.
Obwohl dieses Teil unten ja grün war.
Richtig, aber das waren nur Folien, die auf den Automaten klebten. Und beim Space Invaders versuchte man sich auch so einen räumlichen Eindruck mit Spiegeln zu verschaffen. Man sah den Monitor nicht direkt, sondern das ganze Bild wurde auf einen Spiegel geworfen, der dann eben in einem Raum schwebte und dahinter war noch eine Kulisse gemalt und oben drüber farbige Folien geklebt. Erst das macht diesen genialen Eindruck dann von Space Invaders auch aus.
Stimmt, das hat ja immer sowas ganz spaceiges.
Richtig, ja.
Also es sind nur drei verschiedene Monster hier bei Space Invaders, also es sind fünf Zeilen.
Ich hätte jetzt auch gedacht, es sind mehr.
Nee, es sind nur drei. Und das UFO halt. Und unten der, naja, das sieht nicht so schick aus, mit dem man da so schießt. Da kommen die Monster ja irgendwie mehr raus. Aber vor allem der in der Mitte, das ist irgendwie so der mit den Antennen, das ist so der ikonische und so. Aber die drei zusammen, die machen natürlich auch eine Menge her.
Ja, schicko.
Space Invaders ist ja total großartig. Also ich mochte Space Invaders immer gerne und ich mochte auch Asteroids sehr gerne. Asteroids mochte ich sogar richtig super gerne. Wann kam das denn eigentlich dazu?
Ja, das kam dann eigentlich gerade ein Jahr später dann dazu. 79 kam dann Asteroids raus und das war auch wieder von Atari. Ich habe ja gesagt, den Namen Atari werden wir jetzt noch öfters hören. Asteroids lehnt sich ja von der Steuerung her des Raumschiffes auch wieder an Space Warder, Computer Space an. Das heißt, man hat im Prinzip so dieses Needle, man bezeichnet es auch als Needle-Raumschiff, weil es ja wie, wenn man eine Nadel durch das Raumschiff stecken würde und man kann den Kopf des Raumschiffes nach rechts und links mit Knöpfen bewegen und man hat einen zusätzlichen Button, der dann Schub dem Raumschiff verleiht, also man hatte im Prinzip auch schon die erste Physik-Engine in den Spielen, weil man musste, wenn man nicht mehr in eine gewisse Richtung fliegen wollte, auch das Raumschiff umdrehen in die Gegenrichtung und musste dann mit dem Schub gegensteuern. Also es war eine komplexe, aber auch sehr spaßige Steuerung. Und bei Astroid war es ja so, das Hauptthema wäre, dass sehr unwahrscheinlich viele Asteroiden rumflogen. Und wenn einem ein Asteroid traf, dann war man kaputt und man konnte entweder den Asteroiden ausweichen oder man musste die Asteroiden kleinschießen. In dem Moment, wo man Asteroiden traf, wurde der immer kleiner, kleinere Teile, aber die bewegten sich dann auch schneller. Man musste im Prinzip das komplette Bild erst freischießen, um dann in das nächste Level zu gelangen. Asteroids ist auch ein besonderer Automat, was die Technik angeht, denn der Asteroids-Automat hatte keinen normalen Rastagrafikmonitor, also so wie wir es jetzt heute von den Fernseher kennen oder wie es alle Computer gemacht haben, sondern er hatte einen Vektorbildschirm. Das heißt, dieser Monitor hatte eine andere Technik. Da wurde das Bild nicht in Form von einer Matrix dargestellt, in einer Punktmatrix, in der der Aufbau des Bildes ja zeilenweise stattfindet. Deshalb sprühe ich mir auch von einem Rastamonitor, sondern der war Vektor-basierend, das heißt, die Objekte, die sich auf dem Bildschirm befanden, die wurden in Koordinaten definiert. Das heißt, als einfaches Beispiel, das dreieckige Raumschiff, das war nicht ganz dreieckig, aber stellt euch mal vor, man will jetzt ein Raumschiff zeichnen, das dreieckig aussieht, dann braucht man drei Koordinaten, die die Eckpunkte dieses Raumschiffs beschreiben. Und der Kathodenstrahl dann von diesem Monitor, der zeichnete im Prinzip dann oder verband dann diese Eckpunkte untereinander. Und damit hatte man ein ganz klares und deutliches Bild, das heißt eine schräge Linie zum Beispiel. Die war richtig schräg, die war auch aalglatt. Also bei einem Raster-Grafikmonitor war eine schräge Linie nicht schräg, sondern die hatten kleine Treppenstufen, also je nachdem, wie fein das Raster ist. Und die meisten Arcade-Automaten, die hatten eine Auflösung von 256 mal 256. Und es ist klar, dass man dann Artefakte hat oder Treppenstufen dann bei einer schrägen Linie. Und das war das Besondere bei Astroids, dass man ein richtig klares Bild hatte.
Ja, das ist total irre, weil was ihr im Prinzip gemacht, das sind normalerweise normale Raster-Zeilen-Bildschirme, der Name sagt es ja schon, macht halt Raster-Zeilen, das heißt die Kathodenstrahl, der Kathodenstrahl da hinten wird einfach bei default halt immer durch eine Zeile gejagt und dann wieder nach vorne geschickt, durch eine Zeile gejagt, wieder nach vorne geschickt. Aber da hat quasi die Software selber diese Steuerung übernommen und es wurde halt nicht einfach in Zeilen vorgegangen, sondern hat einfach genau da den Strahl auf diese phosphoreszierende Schicht draufgehauen, wo er eben gerade eine Linie haben wollte und dann wieder ausgeschaltet, dann zum nächsten Teil, was gemalt werden musste und das eben so schnell, dass eben die Wiederholrater auch ausgereicht hat, um einen wirklich extrem flüssigen Ablauf zu machen.
Es war auch der Vorteil von solchen Vektorbildschirmen, dass man extrem flüssige und schnelle Bewegungen zu der damaligen Zeit darstellen konnte, was mit Raster, Grafikmonitoren so noch nicht möglich war. Deshalb ist ja auch Astroids ein extrem schnelles Spiel.
Man braucht auch wenig Speicher, ne?
Richtig, ja. Weil man ja im Prinzip nur die Koordinaten bestimmt.
Aber wie haben die das mit der Kollision dann irgendwie gelöst? Das ist ja schon relativ tricky. Dann sozusagen auch wirklich genau dieses berührt den anderen...
Ja gut, in dem Moment, wo sich die eine Koordinate mit der gleichen Koordinate mehr oder weniger trifft.
Stimmt, die malen ja...
Genau.
Die malen ja, okay, verstehe.
Richtig, weil die Astroiden bestanden ja auch nur aus Vektorpunkten. Also von daher kann man es schon gut definieren.
Ja, war auf jeden Fall schon ein pfiffiger Ansatz. Sehr. Zu dem Zeitpunkt war ja auch diese ganze Arcade-Industrie dann auch schon langsam eine, oder? Also ich meine, so Midway, den du jetzt genannt hast, die waren ja auch in dem Flipper-Business schon auch sehr groß. Also das war ja sozusagen nicht so, dass die nur Computerspiele gemacht hätten, sondern da ging es generell, es waren sozusagen Automatenaufsteller.
Recht, es waren Automatenaufsteller und auch 75 haben die schon gemercht mit Bully. Also Bully ist eigentlich ein Begriff in der Pinball-Szene. Und Midway war mehr oder weniger ein Automatenhersteller, weniger ein Pinball-Hersteller. Und durch diesen Merch gab es eine große und einflussreiche Firma in dieser ganzen Arcade- und Spielhallenszene. Aber der richtige Run und der richtige Boom ging dann halt mit Space Invaders, Asteroids und all den Automaten. Also man spricht ja auch, wie ich vorher schon erwähnt habe, von der goldenen Ära der Videospiele, die wirklich 78 begann und dann 82 ihr Ende fand. Und die meisten, heute noch Ikonen der Arcade-Spiele, die sind genau in dieser Zeit entstanden. Also in diesen vier, fünf Jahren. Also der zeitliche Übergang ist da ein bisschen fließend.
Was ist da noch passiert? Also was sind die anderen Ikonen, die du so nennen würdest?
Da haben wir Galaxian, da haben wir Defender, da haben wir Missile Command, da haben wir Donkey Kong, da haben wir Pac-Man. Alle die Dinge, die man so heute kennt, die sind wirklich genau in dieser Zeit entstanden. In diesen vier Jahren, das ist schon verrückt. Eigentlich hatten wir ja eine relativ lange Halbwertszeit, was so Videospiele anging. Ich habe es ja gesagt, Pong hat sich ja über Jahre gehalten, oder das Pong-Prinzip. Aber genau in dieser Zeit, das war auch die kreativste Zeit, da entstanden ja auch total ihre Spiele.
Warum nur da und nicht mehr darüber hinaus?
Das hatte mehrere Faktoren. Es hatte zum einen den Faktor, dass die Homecomputer und die Konsolen auch immer stärker waren. Oder stärker wurden dann zu der Zeit. Also wenn wir jetzt von 82 reden, da kamen ja dann auch schon Geräte.
VC20, C64 später.
Richtig, C64 auf die Bildfläche. Und Konsolen wie Colecovision, Intellivision oder Atari 2600, die hatten ja auch vorher schon ein bisschen so den Markt abgegrast.
Das heißt eigentlich eine extrem schnelle Entwicklung. Also gerade Mitte der 70er Jahre waren die Geräte, war man überhaupt technisch soweit, diese Geräte effizient herzustellen, sodass überhaupt viele Sachen dafür poämiert werden konnten. Mikroprozessionen wurden eingesetzt, etc. 78 ging es richtig ab. Das heißt da war dann sozusagen Mikrocomputertechnologie zwar nutzbar genug, um diesen Maschinen sozusagen den Schub zu geben, aber eben noch nicht ausreichend, um so einen Heimcomputermarkt zu begründen. Das war so die Zeit, wo für einen Heimcomputer, da musste ja noch so einiges erfunden werden. Zu dem Zeitpunkt 78, was hat man da bekommen? Da hat man so Geräte bekommen, die konnte man noch, die hatten noch keine Tastatur. Da musste man vielleicht noch selber DIP-Schalter umlegen. Wobei, jetzt sind wir natürlich auch schon in der Gründungsphase von Apple. Apple I und dann natürlich vor allem der Apple II. War aber natürlich auch alles noch sehr teuer. Und musste auch erstmal langsam seinen Markt finden. Während die dicken Maschinen einfach in der Arcade standen und nur ein paar Penny gekostet haben.
Weil du gerade Apple ansprichst, wusstest du, dass Steve Jobs einmal Atari-Angestellter war?
Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was er da gemacht hat, aber dass er da war.
Ja, der war der Angestellte mit der Nummer 40 bei Atari. Also der war wirklich in den Anfängen auch mit dabei. Und der hat damals für Atari auch ein Spiel, also er hat verschiedene Dinge für Atari gemacht. Also war das nicht Breakout? Ja, richtig. Also er musste verschiedene Projekte betreuen bei Atari. Aber das Projekt, mit dem man ihn auch immer verbindet, ist Breakout. Und Breakout kam da 1976 auf die Bildfläche. Und das war ganz witzig. Nolan Baschnell hat ihm damals den Auftrag gegeben, entwickelt doch bitte dieses Breakout. Also Breakout ist so was Ähnliches wie ein Pong-Klon. Das heißt, man hat auch einen Spielball, der an den Wänden und am Schläger abprallt. Aber man hat oben eine Wand von Bausteinen, die man versucht, mit diesem Ball abzuräumen. Also das Spielprinzip wurde Steve Jobs vorgegeben, also von Atari oder von Nolan Baschnell. Aber die Entwicklung sollte er durchführen.
Hat er das selber gemacht, oder hat er das nicht schon mit Wozniak zusammengebracht?
Das hat er mit Wozniak zusammengebracht. Ich denke, das hätte er allein gar nicht hinbekommen. Wir wissen ja, dass Steve, sag ich mal, der Guru an sich ist, aber nicht der Techniker. Der Techniker war der Salesman. Richtig. Und da gab es einen Deal.
Erinnerst du dich, was mir gerade einfällt? Der erste iPod hatte ja auch ein Spiel drauf.
Genau. Richtig. Es lässt sich ja aber super steuern über das Clickwheel. Man muss ja nur nach rechts oder nach links fahren.
Sonst wissen wir auch alle, warum.
Ja, eigentlich kann eigentlich Steve Jobs gar nicht so stolz darauf sein. Denn damit ist auch noch ein bisschen eine schlechte Geschichte für ihn verbunden. Denn alleine konnte er es nicht entwickeln. Er holte sich Steve Wozniak zur Hilfe, der ja wirklich der geniale Schrauber war.
Der Tinker bei euch schlechthin war, ja.
Und Nolan Baschnell sagte eben, wenn du das Projekt realisierst, bekommst du von mir 750 Dollar. Und er sagte Steve Wozniak, okay, wenn du mir hilfst, dann teilen wir uns da das Geld. Nolan Baschnell legte noch eins drauf und sagte, aber nur Steve Jobs natürlich, jeder IC, der nicht auf der Platine ist, der spart uns Geld und der ist noch ein Bonus für dich von 100 Dollar.
Für jeden IC?
Für jeden IC. Und Steve Wozniak war ein genialer IC-Verhinderer, sage ich jetzt mal. In vier schlaflosen Tagen hat er das Spiel Breakout auf die Beine gestellt und hat sage und schreibe 40 ICs oder so weniger benötigt. Ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht mehr sicher über die Zahl, aber es waren 40 ICs weniger. Ja, es waren 50 ICs, das waren nämlich 5.000 Dollar. Und die 5.000 Dollar, die hat er nie gesehen.
Steve, du Sau.
Erst später, also wirklich viele Jahre später, als Apple dann so richtig in ihrer Blütezeit war, so 82, glaube war das, oder 83, hat er über diesen Deal erfahren und war dann wirklich zu Tote gekränkt. Also ich denke, das war dann auch der Hauptbruch zwischen Steve und Wozniak. Ich meine, die haben ja immer noch ein gutes freundschaftliches Verhältnis, aber nicht mehr so dieses Nerd-Verhältnis wie früher.
Tja, ja, ein bisschen Aufrichtigkeit kann nicht schaden. Wie sind wir denn da jetzt hingekommen?
Wir sind über Apple hingekommen und über die Homecomputer entstanden.
Genau, das war sozusagen auch die Zeit, wo das losging. Über Homecomputer wollen wir jetzt nicht so viel reden, aber es ist klar, mit dem Apple wurde quasi die Idee des Personal Computers geboren, später dann besser von IBM vermarktet. Und das kennen wir alle, die Microsoft-Historie, wobei vielleicht kennt ihr auch mittlerweile keinen Mensch mehr, ich weiß gar nicht, vielleicht muss man auch noch mal CIF machen, das ist schon wieder so lange her, wie auch immer. Aber die Game-Automaten, die gab es halt immer noch und hatten im Prinzip jetzt ihre technologische Blüte. Es war einfach immer mehr möglich, sowohl was jetzt die Mikroprozessoren betraf, aber natürlich auch, was die Weiterentwicklung der Computer-Grafik betraf. Und ich schätze mal, nebenbei dürfte ja auch eine ganze Menge passiert sein, was so Joysticks et cetera betrifft. Das war ja eine riesen Nachfrage und entsprechend konnten dann diese Konsolen auch mal mehr. Aber es blieb eigentlich immer bei diesen eine Konsole ein Spielding, oder?
Richtig, ja. Ja, es ist sehr lange. Und man spricht auch bei solchen Automaten von Dedicated-Automaten. Also wenn man heute einen Automaten kauft, bedeutet das, ein Dedicated-Automat ist ein Automat, der speziell für dieses eine Spiel gebaut wurde. Also dessen Gehäuse dann auf dieses Spiel entsprechend designt wurde.
Aber hat das nie jemand probiert, dann auch einfach mal so mehrere Sachen? Ich meine, das ist doch so aus ökonomischen Erwägungen extrem naheliegend.
Die Spielhallenbetreiber haben dann auch irgendwann gesagt, Mensch, warum könnt ihr uns nicht irgendwelche Universalautomaten liefern, in die wir dann einfach nur die Platinen wechseln? Ja, da müssen wir auch nicht ein Automat... Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel den Space Invaders von der hinteren Ecke rechts nach links stellen möchten, weil das optisch dann besser bei uns aussieht, dann müssen wir nicht mehr einen ganzen Automaten bewegen, sondern dann tauschen wir einfach nur das Modul aus. Und das war dann auch so, also 82, 83 begann das dann, dass dann so Universalautomaten dann auf den Mic kamen. So TV Ideal, so Quattros, die haben wir zum Beispiel auch in der Ausstellung. Das sind Vierfachautomaten, das heißt da kann man vier Platinen rein machen. Man hat sogar einen horizontal- und vertikalschwenkbaren Monitor, also der ist drehbar im Automaten.
Dass man sozusagen das eine als auch das andere Format haben kann.
Richtig, man hat dann immer zwei...
So vertikale Ausrichtung war ja nicht selten, also die Länge wurde auch schon häufiger mal...
Am Anfang waren die Automaten eigentlich alle hochkant. Das Horizontale kam eigentlich erst später. Gerade Defender ist so ein Kandidat. Vor allen Dingen war Defender auch der erste Sidescroller, also der über den Bildschirm rannte.
Wo man nicht sozusagen so ein festes Set hatte, sondern wo man einfach weiterfliegen konnte und dann flogst du die Landschaft unter einem durch. Ach echt, Defender war da der erste?
Na ja, Defender war da der erste.
Defender war schon ein totaler Adrenalin-Game. Weil dann auch immer die Dinge aus dem Nichts auftauchten.
Und Defender war ja extrem schnell. Man musste extrem gute Reflexe haben, um Defender zu steuern.
Was war denn so, ich meine du hast ja vorhin Donkey Kong und Pac-Man erwähnt, waren die auch wirtschaftlich so erfolgreich, wie man das heute vermuten würde?
Donkey Kong, gerade Donkey Kong und Pac-Man waren eigentlich die erfolgreichsten Spiele überhaupt. Also gerade Pac-Man. Pac-Man war wirtschaftlich gesehen ein gigantischer Erfolg. Vor allen Dingen löste der auch noch eine Welle der Euphorie, vor allen Dingen in den Staaten aus, was Merchandise-Produkte, also Fremdprodukte, die nichts mit dem Spiel an sich oder mit Arcade zu tun hatten, aus. Da gab es Cornflakes-Packungen mit Pac-Man drauf. Es gab eigene Cartoon-Serien von Pac-Man. Also es ist wirklich irre, was da alles lief.
Pac-Man ist ja auch bis heute fest verankert.
Hat nicht Google sogar...
War das ein Jahrestag von Pac-Man? Ich weiß gar nicht. Sie hatten irgendwie in ihrem Google-Logo auf der Suchseite ein Pac-Man-Game drin, ein JavaScript gemacht. Dann konnte man dann direkt auf der Suchseite Pac-Man spielen.
Richtig, richtig.
Und Pac-Man ist auch... Du hast ja vorher die Geräusche gemacht beim Space Invaders, beim Pac-Man, dieses Wacka, Wacka, Wacka, wenn er diese Kugeln frisst. Das sind auch so Dinge, die einem für immer in Erinnerung bleiben. Genau. Und Pac-Man war zum Beispiel von Namco auch ein bekannter Spielerentwickler, auch ein japanischer Spielerentwickler. Pac-Man wurde wiederum von Midway gepublished. Midway hört man auch immer wieder in diesem Arcade.
Aber er wurde ja nur in den USA von Midway gepublished. In Japan haben die das alles selber gemacht.
In Japan haben sie das selber gemacht. Und bei Pac-Man ist es auch ganz witzig, das Spiel hieß ursprünglich nicht Pac-Man, das hieß Puk-Man. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher. Es gibt so diese Theorie darüber. Aber ich glaube, Puk ist auch eine japanische Bezeichnung für Essen. Oder für Fressen. Genau, der Fressmann. Und wir haben in unserer Ausstellung auch einen Original Puk-Man-Automaten.
Ach so, er wurde auch als Puk-Man tatsächlich mal produziert. Und warum dann Pac-Man?
Und er wurde auch nach Deutschland als Puk-Man geliefert. Erst als er in die Staaten geliefert wurde, mussten die sich was anderes einfallen lassen. Denn so prübertiere Jugendliche kamen natürlich dann gleich auf die Idee, aus dem P vom Puk-Man ein F zu machen. Also mit dem Etting dann einfach an den Automaten. Dann hat man keinen Puk-Man mehr, sondern einen Fak-Man. Das war wirklich der Grund, warum Puk-Man in Pac-Man umbenannt wurde. Krass.
Fak-Man.
Oh, das kriege ich jetzt nicht mehr aus dem Kopf. Ja, und Donkey Kong, da wurde dann das erste Mal die Prinzessin gerettet.
Richtig. Donkey Kong war auch das erste Spiel mit einer Handlung. Das hat der geniale Shigeru Miyamoto erfunden für die Firma Nintendo. Und Nintendo ist ja auch ein ganz wichtiger Name in der Computerspielszene. Und viele denken, Donkey Kong ist der erste Automat, den Nintendo hergestellt hat. Das stimmt aber nicht. Das ist Redascope. Und Redascope ist so eine Art erweiterte Space Invaders-Klon. Und der kam ja auch erst 1981 dann auf den Markt. Der war dann für Nintendo kein so großer Erfolg. Zum einen waren die Leute von Weltraumspielen oder die so ähnlich waren wie Space Invaders übertrössig. Und zum anderen war das Spiel auch nicht so gut umgesetzt. Und dann bekam Shigeru Miyamoto den Auftrag, ein anderes Spiel zu entwickeln. Man hatte noch ganz viele Redascope-Automaten in der Halle stehen. Und er sollte mit dieser Platine, das war eine Vierfachplatine damals, diese Platine umgestalten oder umentwickeln oder ein neues Spiel darauf produzieren. Und er kam dann auf die Idee von Donkey Kong. Das ist ja ein komplett anderes Spielprinzip. Redascope, also Space Invaders-Klonen, sag ich mal. Und Donkey Kong, die haben ja null miteinander zu tun. Und als er das Spiel vorstellte, kann man sich ja vorstellen, was die Vorstände damals gedacht haben. Was spielt der jetzt? Es war ja auch Nintendos letzte Hoffnung. Also Nintendo of America hat sich mit Redascope so dermaßen verschuldet, dass die im Prinzip kurz vorm Konkurs standen. Und Donkey Kong war die letzte Hoffnung von Nintendo of America.
Und das war dann mehr als nur eine Rettung. Weil Prinzessinnen werden da immer noch gerettet. Das hat sich ja bis Mario und fast nicht alles an Varianten bei Nintendo produziert wird. Das ist ja irgendwie echt super gehalten.
Also ohne Donkey Kong und ohne Shigeru Miyamoto, der noch viele andere Nintendo-Charaktere entwickelt hat, wäre Nintendo nicht das, was sie heute sind. Das darf man nicht vergessen.
Ja, es ist interessant, wie die sich auch da gewandelt haben. Die gab es ja auch schon vorher. Die sind ja nicht gegründet worden dafür. Das war mal ein Spielkartenhersteller.
Richtig, ja.
Die gibt es ja schon seit Urzeiten.
Genau, die hatten zuerst mal Spielkarten hergestellt und dann auch elektronische Spieler. Es gab auch einen Pong-Klon von Nintendo. Aber die erste eigene Arcade-Maschine war dann, wie gesagt, RadarScope. Und Donkey Kong wurde auch in den ersten Automatengehäusen von RadarScope verbaut. Es waren dann noch so rote Gehäuse und die typischen amerikanischen Gehäuse, die blauen, die kamen dann erst später, als dann alle alten RadarScope-Gehäuse aufgebraucht waren.
Also der Shigeru Miyamoto ist ja die mythische Person eigentlich bei Nintendo, oder?
Schon so ein Held, quasi der Steve Jobs der Videospiel-Szene.
Entwickelt der immer noch?
Ja, der entwickelt immer noch für Nintendo. Also bekannte Charaktere, die er designt hat, sind zum Beispiel Zelda, also The Legend of Zelda. Er hat aber auch so Dinge vorgebracht wie jetzt Wii-Music. Was denke ich sicherlich im Nachhinein nicht. Ja, in der Hobenhalle wird sich dieses Spiel nicht finden. Oder Pikmin oder viele andere Charaktere aus dem Nintendo-Universum. Und er hat ein ganz besonderes Talent. Er hat wirklich das Talent, zum einen Geschichten zu erzählen, ganze Szenerien sich auszumalen, Stories. Und er hat auch das Talent, irgendwie alles kompakt zu machen, alles rund zu machen. Das gab es in der Vergangenheit auch noch nicht. In Space Invaders musste man einfach irgendwelche Aliens abknallen. Da hatte man ein Bild und das war's. Mit Donkey Kong erzählte man das erste Mal eine Geschichte. Also damals war es noch kein Klempner, sondern ein Bauarbeiter, der im Prinzip eine Prinzessin retten muss vor dem King Kong, der sie geklaut hat. Und es war auch das erste Spiel mit mehreren Bildern, mit mehreren Levels. Also Donkey Kong hat ja vier Bilder.
How high can you go?
How high can you go, genau. Deshalb auch Level. Ich meine, da ging es auch darum.
Level... Genau, so habe ich das noch gar nicht gesehen. Stimmt. Man klettert immer höher. Das heißt, dass ein Level tatsächlich kommt aus diesem Spiel. Kann man das behaupten?
Ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht sicher, ob der Begriff Level schon vorher auf der Bildfläche war. Aber ich glaube nicht. Ich könnte mir das schon gut vorstellen.
Ich kenne jetzt auch so kein Spiel, was wirklich in Level so aufgeteilt war. Ich meine, bei Asteroids, da, wenn man alles abgeknallt hat, dann kam dann immer mehr in dem Sinne. Aber da zählt nicht wirklich ein Level hoch. Das war halt einfach immer nur mehr.
Richtig, richtig. Es waren alle schneller. Es war immer nur ein Bild.
Püffig, püffig. Also bei Nintendo und eben dann auch bei Donkey Kong, da kam auch eine ganz andere Emotion noch mit rein. Ich meine, erst mal so dieses Prinzessin-Retten, das ist natürlich auch schon mal ein ganz anderes Ziel, als jetzt immer nur alles zu zerstören. Richtig. Ich bin zwar ein großer Asteroids-Fan, aber ich kann eigentlich so mit Baller Games, kann ich noch nie was anfangen, und bei Person-Shooter schalte ich irgendwie komplett ab. Aber so Prinzessin-Retten, das ist natürlich auch was Romantisches. Da kommt auch so eine Emotion mit rein. Ich war, da ist man irgendwie oben, da hat man sie fast, und dann wieder gebrochenes Herz, und der Affe klettert wieder noch ein Hör-Buhu, bis man es geschafft hat und sie dann mal wirklich kriegt.
Das war ja auch so schön umgesetzt, und das ist ja auch die Kunst, die Shigeru Miyamoto eigentlich auch drauf hat. Also diese Geschichte tatsächlich zu erzählen, was du gerade angesprochen hast, dieses gebrochene Herz, oder bei einem Level fällt dann Donkey Kong, dann auf den Kopf, verdreht dann die Augen. So alles Nebensächliche, wo sich früher die Programmierer gar keine Mühe gegeben haben. Wo sie einfach gedacht haben, das Spiel muss einfach Spaß machen in dem Moment, das muss gar nicht wirken. Und Shigeru Miyamoto hat wirklich das Talent, ein Spiel, ich finde, der beste Begriff ist, er macht das Spiel einfach rund, er macht das kompakt, er erfüllt dieses ganze Spiel aus, auch mit Nebensequenzen. Für ihn ist auch wichtig, was passiert auf dem Startbildschirm, was passiert auf diesen Zwischensequenzen, auch bei den aktuellen Spielen zum Beispiel, wo es darum geht, welche Spieler wähle ich aus und so weiter. Das ist für ihn alles wichtig.
Musikalisch?
Musikalisch natürlich auch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das vorher war, aber Donkey Kong habe ich auch immer gleich so den Zwischenlevel-Sound im Kopf.
Ja, da kommt ja auch... Es ist ja nur eine Phrase, es ist ja kein richtiges Lied, was da gespielt wird.
Aber es ist irgendwie entscheidend. Das verheiratet einen auch irgendwie schon enorm mit dieser Welt und das ist ja auch das, was sich später daraus so entwickelt hat. Also gerade jetzt auch diese ganzen Fortsetzungsgeschichten, Zelda und dieses romantische Abenteuer-Ding, Aufgaben lösen, Abenteuer erleben. Das Ganze eben in so einer kompletten Welt, auch bei Mario, findet man das alles wieder. Das war quasi alles bei Donkey Kong das erste Mal.
Richtig, und Donkey Kong war auch der erste Plattform. Der hat im Prinzip auch ein neues Spiele-Genre gegründet.
Was meinst du mit Plattform?
Mit Plattform bezeichnet man die Spiele, wo man sich von einer Plattform auf die nächste bewegt, so wie es beim Donkey Kong...
Meinst du jetzt das Hochklettern oder diese Level?
Nein, ich meine jetzt das Hochklettern. Dass man eine Spielfigur auf einer Plattform bewegt.
Dass sie nicht nur unten ist und alles abschießt, sondern hoch und runter klettert.
Vorher kannte man nur die Shooter, dann die Rennspiele oder die Sportspiele. Und mit Donkey Kong gab es dann auch den ersten Plattformer. Später die Weiterentwicklung wie Super Mario oder Super Mario Bros. Das waren ja dann auch alles Plattformer.
D.h., man könnte sogar fast sagen, aus dieser Superzeit... Was war das, 1978 bis 1982, wo diese ganzen Arcade-Maschinen ihren Kick hatten und wo so viele wegweisende Spiele gemacht wurden? Ist Donkey Kong in gewisser Hinsicht noch das Wegweisendste? Oder gab es noch andere Wegweisende?
Wenn ich jetzt Ja sage, werden viele in Deutschland sagen.
Was werden die dann sagen? Andere Leute haben eine andere Meinung. Die Frage ist, welche Spiele könnte man sonst noch heranziehen? Defender hattest du schon genannt mit diesem Side-Scroller. Das ist dann sozusagen auch ein neues Element, was dann auch später nicht unpopulär war.
Ich würde sagen, Donkey Kong war sicherlich für die Videospielindustrie, unabhängig von den Arcade-Automaten, sicherlich eines der wichtigsten Spiele überhaupt.
Und was war denn überhaupt so, man zieht sich ja im Prinzip heute in so eine Arcade-Hölle. Kann man diesen Namen überhaupt benutzen? Diese Spieleautomaten, Hallen, hineingeht, was ist da populär? Diese Kämpfdinger, das gab es ja irgendwie so noch gar nicht in der Zeit. Dieses Kung Fu, Tra-la-la, ich haue dir auf die Fresse-Spiele, die sind in der Zeit so gar nicht aktiv gewesen.
Doch, 1984 gab es zum Beispiel Karate-Chamber oder sowas von Data East. Das waren auch schon so die ersten Kung Fu-Spiele. Aber da ging es nicht ums Prügeln oder ums Vernichten oder so, sondern es war ein richtiges, echtes, ehrliches Kung Fu-Spiel, sage ich mal. Diese richtigen Prügler, die du jetzt ansprichst, die kamen dann erst in den 90er-Jahren. Die Jahre waren auch geprägt von Genres, die in diesen Jahren besonders berühmt waren. Nein, ich meine das jetzt nicht auf Filme bezogen, sondern zu gewissen Jahreszeiten waren auch Genre sehr verbreitet. Zum Beispiel bis Mitte der 80er-Jahre, würde ich sagen, war es ein bunter Mischmasch von allen Möglichen. Und alles, was nach 1985 kam, das waren in erster Linie viele Kriegsspiele, in denen man mit einer echten Maschinengewehr, sage ich mal, wie Operation Thunderbolt oder Operation Wolf oder so, wo man irgendetwas abschoss, oder Terminator, beziehungsweise diese Multiplayer-Automaten, wie ein Gauntlet oder ein Quartett, wo mehrere Spieler... Was ist das Gauntlet? Gauntlet ist auch ein Spiel von Atari. Das ist wie ein Dungeons & Dragons Spiel angelehnt an diese Thematik. Da kann einer den Part eines Elfen übernehmen, der andere den Part eines Zauberers, der nächste den Part eines Kriegers. Man kann mit maximal vier Personen an einem Automat spielen. Man muss sich dann durch die Dungeons durchkämpfen. Und genau dieses Genre der Multiplayer-Automaten war Ende der 80er Jahre sehr populär. Also mehrere Personen an einem Automat spielen konnten. Und dann die Prügler, die du angesprochen hast, die kamen dann in den 90er Jahren auf, wie Mortal Kombat, Killer Instinct. Man muss mal aufpassen, gewisse Spiele stehen auch auf dem Index. Und dürfen im Podcast gar nicht erwähnt werden. Wenn ich muss vielleicht auspiepsten oder so.
Aber so ein Dauerbrenner ist natürlich auch Autofahren. Wie hieß das Ding? Du hast ja vorhin schon so ein Autofahrer gespielt.
Grand Track 10 von Atari.
Aber so richtig erfolgreich war doch später erst Pole Position, oder?
Richtig, richtig. Pole Position. Weil Grand Track 10 hatte ja die Draufsicht auf die Rennstrecke. Es war noch ein ganz anderes Spiel wie solche Rennspiele, die wir heute kennen, die quasi eine Simulation des realen Lebens darstellen sollen. Und Pole Position war das erste Spiel, was genau diese Sicht auf den Spieler war.
Das ist interessant, weil an der Stelle alles andere ist immer so maximale Fantasie und maximale Realitätsflucht. Weltraum, King Kongs, die Prinzessinnen in Zauberwelten entführen, etc. Das ist ja alles nicht von dieser Welt. Zumindest nicht von der unmittelbaren Umgebung. Aber Autofahren, das macht jeder. Das heißt, die Simulation der Realität steht da quasi auch in direkter Konkurrenz, wenn man die Automaten alle nebeneinander sieht, zu den Fantasiewelten. Welcher Spieler fühlt sich denn welchem Genre da mehr zu geneigt? Ihr seid ja hier auch ein Verein, ihr habt Leute, die alle eure Lieblingsspieler haben. Kannst du da irgendwie so was ableiten? Welche Art Games, welche Art Menschen jetzt besonders anziehen?
Also auf einen Menschen kann man es eigentlich nicht beziehen, auf eine Art von Menschen oder so. Aber es ist wirklich so, es gibt Leute, die lieben einfach solche Simulationen. Und die lieben die auch heute noch. Also die spielen gerne Formel-1-Spiele oder die spielen gerne ein FIFA oder Pro Evolution Soccer. Das sind dann mehr so die Simulationsfreaks. Die versuchen in ihrem Computerspiel das reale Leben dann auch wieder aufleben zu lassen. Oder Dinge zu machen, die man gerne im realen Leben machen würde, wie z.B. Formel-1-Auto fahren, aber die man dann nicht kann.
Wo man nicht so richtig dazu kommt. Na gut, das Mondfliegen würde man ja vielleicht auch im realen Leben gerne mal machen, so ein paar Raumschiffe abschießen, wenn es welche gäbe. Also du kannst da jetzt nichts dran festmachen und fährst mal nur so ein bisschen.
Nein, würde ich nicht sagen.
Was gab es denn noch an einflussreichen Entwicklungen jenseits von Donkey Kong?
Ja, also gerade in der Zeit in dieser goldenen Ära kamen dann auch noch Automaten hoch, wie Frogger, Galaga, Galaxian. Galaxian war zum Beispiel einer der ersten Farbautomaten. Also alle Automaten davor, die waren noch schwarz-weiß. Galaxian war das erste Farbspiel, 1979. Das war ein relativ frühes Spiel, sogar Galaxian.
Und Phönix fällt auch in diese Zeit, glaube ich?
Phönix kam ein bisschen später.
Das war, wo alles angefangen hat zu flattern. Vögel waren auch ein interessantes Meme, was sich da immer wieder gefunden hat. Vögel im Weltall.
Vögel im Weltall ist auch ganz interessant. Es gibt ein Spiel, das heißt Joust. Ich weiß nicht, ob dir das was sagt. Das kennen wenige. Joust? Joust steht ja für Turnier, für eine Fede zwischen zwei Rittern oder für ein Ritterturnier. Es geht auch darum, dass sich zwei Ritter bekriegen. Aber es wird sicher an diesem Automaten. Ich finde auch, Joust ist ein Automat, der mir persönlich sehr gut gefällt, weil er auch diese Kreativität und dieses Abgedrehtsein, was man damals noch bei der Spielerentwicklung haben konnte, auch widerspiegelt. Diese Ritter, die ritten nicht auf Pferden, sondern auf einem Vogelstrauß. Also ein Vogelstrauß, auf dem kann man ja reiten und der kann ja auch laufen. Und in diesem Spiel konnte das sogar ein bisschen fliegen, was ein Vogelstrauß in Wirklichkeit gar nicht kann. Und das hatte auch so ein bisschen physikalische Spielmechanik. Also mit dem Button, wenn man auf den Button drückte, dann fing der Vogelstrauß an zu flattern. Und je länger man und je schneller man auf dem Button drückte, umso höher und schneller flatterte der Vogelstrauß auch. Und was auch ganz interessant war an dieser Spielmechanik, war die Tatsache, man musste sicher versuchen, gegenseitig vom Vogelstrauß zu schucken. Und das war so ausgelegt, je höher, also wenn deine Lanze höher war als die des Gegners, dann hast du gewonnen. War deine Lanze niedriger als die Lanze des Gegners, wenn man sich traf, dann hat der Gegner gewonnen. Und hat dich quasi vom Vogelstrauß geschossen. Und waren die Lansen auf gleicher Höhe, dann war es ein Unentschieden. Man musste im Prinzip versuchen, all die Gegner von ihrem Vogel streusen. Das ist richtig plural. Beim Vogelstrauß muss man versuchen, die Gegner von dem Strauß zu schubsen. Der verwandelte sich dann in ein Ei. Aus diesem Ei schlüpfte dann plötzlich wieder ein neuer Vogelstrauß, der seinen abgeworfenen Reiter wieder einfangen konnte. Um das Ganze dann noch schwieriger zu machen, flog dann ab und zu ein Uhrzeit Pterodactyl durch die Luft, den man dann auch nur an einer Stelle, und zwar am Schnabel, treffen konnte. Der gab extrem viele Punkte, aber das zu erreichen war auch extrem schwer. Eigentlich ein ganz abgedrehtes Szenario. Das vermisse ich bei der heutigen Spieleentwicklung auch ein bisschen, den Mut zu neuen und abgedrehten Ideen.
Man ist immer noch ein bisschen auf der Suche nach der totalen Realität.
Ja, finde ich.
An vielen Stellen, was den ganzen 3D-Aufwand betrifft. Inhaltlich ist das nicht immer Realität, was da abgebildet wird im Sinne von, wie ich sie in der Straße vorfinden kann. Teilweise auch, wenn es um diese Autorennen geht, aber im Wesentlichen irgendwelche Scenarios. Aber es muss extrem toll sein. Es muss hochauflösend sein. Es muss hohe Framerate haben, etc. Da fließt viel Energie rein.
Gerade Autorennen, was du jetzt angesprochen hast, ist ein gutes Beispiel. Im Prinzip hat sich das Spielprinzip gar nicht weiterentwickelt. Ein Pole-Position funktioniert von der reinen Spielmechanik her immer noch genauso wie ein Gran Turismo heute. Das heißt, du hast ein Auto, das auf der Bildschirmmitte sich befindet. Das Szenario außenrum bewegt sich um dieses Auto herum. Mehr passiert eigentlich nicht.
Bei Grand Theft Auto kannst du ja auch noch die Autos klauen.
Ich rede jetzt von Grand Turismo. Das ist ein reines Rennspiel, nicht das GTA.
Ich meine es ja nur so, aber da kann man auch rumfahren und den beiden ein paar Leute umbringen.
Was ich damit sagen möchte, die eigentliche Spielidee oder Grundidee, die wurde in den 70er, 80er Jahren geboren. Alles andere ist nur noch technischer Gimmick oder grafischer Overlay, der darüber gelegt wurde. Das finde ich eigentlich schade. Heutzutage macht man sich viel zu wenig Gedanken über die eigentliche Spielmechanik und den eigentlichen Spielwitz oder Spielreiz, sondern versucht einfach nur ein beeindruckendes, grafisch beeindruckendes Spiel hervorzubringen. Ein bestes Beispiel sind genau diese Simulationen. Klar, bei einer Simulation versucht man natürlich alles besser zu machen, also realitätsnah zu machen. Aber mir fehlt da einfach dieser grundsätzliche Arcade-Gedanke, zu versuchen, etwas Neues zu schaffen. Ich meine, es war ja auch die Zeit damals, wo man auch einfach ein bisschen freier denken konnte. Und heute sieht man das eigentlich nur noch so in Independent-Spielen. Die wenigsten Studios, die ja wirklich viel Geld in die Hand nehmen, die haben überhaupt den Mut dazu, etwas richtig Abgefahrenes zu entwickeln, weil sie einfach das Risiko nicht eingehen wollen, weil auch zu viel Geld dahinter steckt.
Da haben wir natürlich jetzt wieder das Internet, nicht wahr? Mit Browser-Games und ähnlichen Effekten, wo man ja mit relativ wenig Aufwand wiederum große Zielgruppen erreichen kann. Und da ja sozusagen auch mal wieder ein coole Spielidee auch verfangen kann, wenn sie denn sozusagen wirklich gut... Ich meine, aktuelles Beispiel würde mir einfallen, ist halt Minecraft, was gerade rumgeht wie Feuer. Der Typ ist irgendwie binnen kürzester Zeit zum Millionär geworden, weil er einfach alle Leute vollkommen entfacht hat mit diesem...
Ich muss zugeben, ich habe das noch gar nicht gespielt. Aber ich habe es schon, also auf Twitter oder so habe ich es schon...
Ja, da muss man halt, da kann man halt alles Mögliche sich herbeibergwerken. Da muss man halt richtig irgendwie die Dinge zusammenbauen, dann kann man dann irgendwie Feuer machen, dann kann man auch irgendwie seinen Stahl gießen, dann kann man halt Leitungen bauen, dann hat halt irgendjemand da sozusagen in einer riesigen Landschaft sogar einen Computer gebaut, der dann sozusagen in diesem Spiel funktioniert. Und das greift halt wieder um sich. Ich will sagen, es ist nicht so, dass es keine Leute gibt, die keine neuen Ideen geboren werden. Vielleicht fehlt einfach die Architektur, also die Business-Architektur oder auch eher die Abwesenheit einer solchen Business-Architektur, die einen eben unter diesen Zwängen der Skalierung etc. und dem Erfolg, den sie schon immer hatten und den sie weiter haben wollen. Und schuß da beleid bei deinen leisten Effekten. Während man halt jetzt im Internet als freier Spieleprogrammierer, da ist man einfach jung, hat irgendwie eine crazy Idee, wie du schon sagst, dieses total verrückte... Da gab es ja auch früher so irre... Wie heißt denn dieses komische, dieses irre Game, wo man mit diesen Kicks zum Beispiel... Das ist auch von Atari, ne? Mit diesem Stab, wo man diese Fläche immer wieder aufteilen muss. In der Mitte ist dieses verrückte Kicks, was da so herummeandert. Und wenn man halt noch in der freien Fläche ist und versucht, was abzuschneiden, und man wird von dem Kicks eingefangen, hat man halt verloren. Und dann irgendwie diese komischen Funken, die da auf der Linie... Ich meine, das ist ja eine mega abstrakte Welt, in der man da eintaucht. Da gibt es keine Prinzessinnen, da gibt es keine Straßen, da gibt es keine Leute, die man bekämpfen muss, sondern da gibt es irgendwie nur komische geometrische Figuren. Und man muss selber auch geometrisch arbeiten. Trotzdem packend.
Da steht wirklich die Spielidee und die Spielmechanik im Vordergrund. Und weniger das Grafische drum herum. Damals hatte man ja auch ressourcentechnisch und auch vom Computer her und von der technischen Leistung her hatte man ja auch gar nicht die Möglichkeit oder konnte man ja auch gar nicht dran denken, irgendetwas Grafisch-Aufwendiges zu machen. Man war ja limitiert. Und diese Limitierung hat ja auch wirklich dazu geführt, dass man mehr über das eigentliche Spiel nachdenken musste. Und über die Präsentation in diesem engen Rahmen, den man damals hatte.
Früher war alles besser.
Ja, echt. Also, ich will nicht sagen besser. Aber viele Spielideen, die meisten Spiele von heute, die passieren alle auf ursprüngliche Spieleideen. Da kam selten mal was richtig Neues dazu, was Spielmechanik angeht.
Ja, beziehungsweise es hat sich dann anders entwickelt. Ich meine gerade das Internet, Multiplayer, Online-Games etc. Das sind ja einfach ganz andere Dimensionen, die so damals ja überhaupt gar nicht realisierbar waren. Die überhaupt nicht zur Diskussion standen. Und wo man sich jetzt erstmal austobt.
Aber da ist ja der technische Background das Entscheidende. Und nicht die Spielideen an sich. Also an den Spielideen hat sich leider nicht viel entwickelt. Sondern nur dieser andere technische Background hat dazu geführt, dass neue Ideen entwickelt wurden. Wie jetzt diese Multiplayer, Massiflé-Multiplayer, Online-Spiele oder so.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, man kann sagen, so was wie SimCity und natürlich auch jetzt die ganzen Vorläufer von World of Warcraft. Warcraft und all diese ganzen Strategiespiele, die man vor allem lange spielt. Ja, ein Arcade-Game ist ja auch dann am Ende immer noch etwas, das spielt man dann vielleicht fünf Stunden lang, aber dann hat man es auch hundertmal gespielt. Es sei denn, man ist auf der Suche nach dem finalen Highscore. Aber es ist ja eigentlich ein sehr kurzatmiges Spiel. Man speichert nicht ab, man hat da keinen Zustand, man trägt da nicht seinen Highscore oder seinen ewigen Ruhm immer wieder mit sich mit. Man hat da auch keinen USB-Stick reingesteckt und seinen Highscore durch die Gegend gemacht, geschweige denn, dass man im Internet sowas hat. Also es sind ja auch andere Bedingungen.
Das war ja auch gar nicht gewünscht. Man versucht ja eigentlich, ein möglichst kurzes Spielerlebnis zu realisieren. Also je mehr eingeworfen wurde in den Automaten, umso nukrativer war der Automat. Und dieses Spagat, was da die Entwicklerfirmen schaffen mussten, zwischen dem eigentlichen Reiz und dem Spaß, den es dem Spieler vermitteln soll und dann aber trotzdem noch einem gewissen Quäntchen an Schwierigkeit, damit er nicht einfach fünf Stunden spielt und den Automaten belegt und niemand anderes mehr spielen kann. Es war echt schwierig.
Stimmt, das ist wirklich ein irres Abwägen. Spieler fünf Stunden, dann warst du die zehn Penny auch nicht wert.
Und trotzdem gab es Spieler, die das tatsächlich schafften. Es gab zum Beispiel einen Spieler, der stellte den Dauer-Weltrekord im Space Invaders auf, der spielte 38 Stunden am Stück. Also es ist irre, wenn man sich das vorstellt, dass das überhaupt möglich ist.
Das war aber bestimmt ein Japaner, oder?
Nein, das war ein Amerikaner.
Echt?
Das war, ich glaube, Fura hieß der. Und nachdem ist sogar ein Bug benannt, den der Automat hatte, den der hatte herausgefunden, dass wenn er 21 Mal irgendwo hinschießt, egal ob er jetzt einen Alien trifft oder nicht, also wenn er 21 Mal schießt und dann nach diesem 21. Mal eines dieser UFOs, die dann ab und zu beim Space Invaders oben schweben, dann abschießen und dann bekommt er 300 Punkte für ein UFO. Das war ziemlich viel, 300 Punkte beim Space Invaders.
Was kriegt man normalerweise?
Ja, für das UFO zum Beispiel 50 Punkte in der Regel.
Für die Invaders sind weniger. Da hast du ja die ganze Zeit immer so seine Schüsse mitgezählt.
Genau, und dann waren es 14 Schüsse, da musste man 14 Schüsse abgeben und das wiederholte sich dann diese 14. Das war so ein Random-Bug in dem Automaten. Es gibt auch viele andere Automaten, die Bugs haben, zum Beispiel Frogger ist so ein ganz verbuggter Automat. Viele Automaten hatten einen Killscreen, das heißt bis zu einem gewissen Punkt konnte man den Automaten spielen, wenn man so gut war und dann ging es nicht mehr weiter, weil die Programmierer gar nicht damit gerechnet haben, dass jemand an dieses Level des Automaten kommt. Donkey Kong zum Beispiel, den kann man bis zum Level 22 spielen. Alles darüber hinaus. Also der Automat hört dann einfach auf, der stellt dann irgendwelche ASCII-Zeichen da, und das war es dann bis zum Level 22. Und auch die Weltrekordhalter von Donkey Kong-Automaten, die spielen natürlich alle nur bis zum Level 22. Es gibt im Prinzip eine feste Grenze an diesem Automat. Und man muss versuchen......nur bis viele Punkte zu kriegen. Exakt, ja. Zum Beispiel beim Donkey Kong gibt es zwei verschiedene Rekorde. Es gibt einen Rekord, da darf man den Hammer benutzen. Und es gibt einen Highscore, wo man den Hammer nicht benutzen kann.
Oh, wie kriegt man denn Punkte ohne Hammer?
Indem man einfach über die Fässer sprengt, da bekommt man auch schon Punkte. Oder indem man einfach das Level meistert, dann bekommt man auch schon Punkte, also diese Bonuspunkte.
Aber es ist interessant, die Arcade-Maschinen haben aber zumindest eine gewisse Vergleichbarkeit gebracht, weil die Spiele natürlich mehr oder weniger weltweit in mehr oder weniger derselben Formen vorlag. Aber teilweise waren die auch sehr unterschiedlich, oder? In ihren Rollouts, europäische Versionen, oder war das dann doch das Gleiche?
Nicht immer, nicht immer. Also die meisten ROMs waren schon gleich, beziehungsweise es gab auch verschiedene Versionen von ROMs. Also wenn die Hersteller festgestellt haben, da ist ein Back drin oder so, dann versuchte man schon neue ROMs zu produzieren, aber natürlich nicht wie heute, wo man sich einen Patch runterladen kann. Da kamen dann vielleicht ein oder zwei Versionen raus von einem Spiel.
Was ja auch diese Arcade-Kultur extrem kulturell mal festgehalten hat, ist ja der Film Tron.
Und nächstes Jahr, 2011, kommt ja der Nachfolger Tron Legacy. Und da freue ich mich schon tierisch drauf.
Was weißt du darüber?
Ah, da gibt es schon einen Trailer im Netz. Also es ist wieder ein Film von Disney. Und jetzt mit diesen ganzen CGI-Möglichkeiten, die man hat.
Das war ja eigentlich der erste Film, der wirklich diese Computer-3D-Optik wirklich auf Zelluloid gebannt hat. Und hat damals noch mit ganz abenteuerlichen Tricks, die teilweise auch im Computer gemacht wurden. Ich bin mir jetzt über die Prozeduren am einzelnen gar nicht so im Plan. Aber diese Idee, dass ich werde in diese Arcade-Automaten hineingepartikuliert. Mit so einem Rasterstrahl, eigentlich Punkt für Punkt aufgelöst. Und wird dann auch selber Teil des Master-Control-Programms. Man ist dann sozusagen ein Programm.
Richtig, also die Spieleentwickler der Arcade-Automaten, die fand man dann im Prinzip in den Chips der Arcade-Automaten. Also jeder Entwickler hatte da ein Alias im Automaten. So auch der Hauptdarsteller Jeff Bridges dann. Und was du gerade angesprochen hast, der Film war ja auch besonders interessant durch die Technik, die verwendet wurde. Es wurde von Disney gemacht und die haben die sogenannte Backlit-Animation-Technik verwendet. Das heißt, viele Szenen wurden in schwarz-weiß aufgenommen und wurden dann im Prinzip über mehrere Schichten nachkoloriert. Also diese ganzen Effekte, die man in den Anzügen hatte, wenn sich das dann im Computer abspielt, die Szenen im Computer, die wurden dann im Prinzip alle nachträglich nachkoloriert. Also es war extrem aufwendig.
Aber eine irre Ästhetik, die natürlich bei dem Film rüber kam. Und der Kult hat sich bis heute gehalten, das ist natürlich auch der Grund, warum es da eine Fortsetzung gibt. Hoffen wir mal, dass es nicht den Weg von so vielen Fortsetzungen geht.
Das hoffe ich natürlich auch. Aber weil du gerade Filme ansprichst, wer sich für Arcade interessiert, der sollte unbedingt einen Film gesehen haben. Da geht es weniger darum, dass im Film Arcade-Automaten vorkommen oder das Thema. Sondern da dreht sich wirklich alles nur um Arcade. Und das ist der The King of Kong. Ja, The King of Kong. Das ist eine Dokumentation über zwei Arcadespieler, die den Highscore im Donkey Kong haben. Deshalb heißt der Film auch King of Kong. Das ist zum einen Steve Weeby, der damals der Herausforderer war, und Billy Mitchell, der damalige Rekordhalter beim Donkey Kong. Und es gibt eine Organisation in Amerika, die wurde so Anfang der 80er, 82 war es, von Walter Day gegründet. Die heißt Twin Galaxies. Das sage ich das offizielle Scoreboard bei den Arcade-Gamer. Und dort kann man sich seinen erreichten Highscore bestätigen lassen. Das heißt, da muss immer ein Referee, ein Schiedsrichter da sein, der während dem Spiel zuschaut und genau beobachtet, dass da ohne Tricks gespielt wird. Beziehungsweise man konnte dann auch in späteren Jahren auch Videobänder einschicken. Und genau diese Dokumentation beschreibt also diesen Kampf vom Steve Wiebe, der versucht hat, diesen Donkey Kong Rekord zu schlagen. Der es auch tatsächlich dann irgendwie schafft. Also ich will nicht spoilern. Muss man sich einfach angucken. Das ist echt spannend. Allein auch schon die Tatsache, Steve Wiebe wird so als Held dargestellt. Und Billy Mitchell, also der gemeine hinterhältige Spieler. Also auch von den Persönlichkeiten her. Also selbst wenn man sich nicht für Arcade interessiert, ist es eine interessante Psychodokumentation.
Ja, haben wir denn jetzt noch einen ganz großartigen Wurf aus dieser tollen Zeit übersehen?
Ganz viele eigentlich. Da könnten wir noch ganz viele Automaten eigentlich nennen.
Damit nicht, dass uns nachher wieder vorgeworfen wird, wir hätten ja das Wichtigste vergessen.
Also wir haben sicherlich irgendwie was vergessen, weil es gibt so viele Automaten. Was zum Beispiel auch wichtig war, war der Dragon Slayer Automat 1983.
Oh, da habe ich ja auch selber viel Zeit mit verbracht. Das war ja ein merkwürdiges Teil. Das war so ein Laserdisc-Gerät. Das war sozusagen eine ganz andere Methode, aber dafür schon so mit so einem Comic-Style. Also es war eigentlich so ein Videospiel im Sinne von Filmvideospiel.
Da war es eigentlich wirklich so, dass das Spielprinzip nicht im Vordergrund stand, sondern das Umfeld, also die Grafik. Was du bereits gesagt hast, es war eine Animation. Es war ein Cartoon, der ablief. Und man konnte diesen Cartoon mit dem Joystick, das ist jetzt falsch gesagt, wenn ich sage, mit dem Joystick-Steuer.
Man musste irgendwie das Richtige tun.
Genau, man musste einfach nur im richtigen Moment den Joystick in die richtige Richtung bewegen. Also da geht es darum, dass ein Ritter eine Dame in einem Schloss befreien möchte.
Da sind wir wieder mit der Prinzessin.
Genau, Prinzessin. Genau, das wurde gezeichnet von Don Blass, ein Disney-Zeichner, der viele bekannte Disney-Filme bereits gezeichnet hatte. Und eigentlich war es nur ein Cartoon, den man sich ansah. Aber wenn zum Beispiel der Ritter über eine Brücke springen musste, zum richtigen Moment, die auseinander brach, dann musste man wirklich in diesem Moment den Joystick nach vorne bewegen. Und nur damit konnte man dann ein Level weiterkommen oder eine neue Sequenz weiterkommen. Und das Faszinierende war dann halt einfach dieser Cartoon, der dann ablief. Die eigentliche Spielmechanik war eigentlich totaler Mist. Also es war auch sehr schwer zu spielen.
War das Ding erfolgreich? Ich meine, ich habe den mal gespielt, aber keine Ahnung, wie gut das ankam.
Es war extrem erfolgreich, aber nur in der ersten Zeit. Es war so ein Automat, der einen unwahrscheinlichen Hype entwickelte im ersten halben Jahr und dann eigentlich nicht mehr erfolgreich war.
Ja, du hast ja schon erwähnt, so 1982 ging das alles wieder zurück. Mir nützt dir nichts, vermutlich, weil die Homecomputer immer stärker wurden.
Richtig, es gab ja diesen typischen Konsolen-Crash 1982, der ja damals ausgelöst wurde vom Atari 2600 mit diesem IT-Spiel. Da bekam die ganze Spielebranche einen Schlag ab und auch die Arcade-Branche. Man war sich unsicher, man wusste nicht, ob man da noch Geld investieren kann oder nicht. Wollen es die Leute? Die Konkurrenz der Homecomputer wurde immer stärker.
Und es war vor allem auch so ein bisschen, wenn ich mich so richtig dran erinnere, es gab tatsächlich dieses, wollen die Leute überhaupt Computerspiele spielen noch? Oder war das jetzt sozusagen der Hype?
Ja, doch.
War das sozusagen nur so ein erster Verbinder mit dieser Technik, aber eigentlich wollen wir alle dann doch lieber Tabellenkalkulationen machen den ganzen Tag. Weil ja auch alle sich, was war denn nochmal dieser Grund mit diesem Atari-Crash? Die haben sich verkalkuliert mit diesem Spiel? Oder haben zu viel produziert und sind nicht losgeworden?
Die hatten viel zu viel produziert und das Spiel war totaler Mist. Also es war eines der schlechtesten Spiele, die überhaupt jemals produziert wurden. Das hat dann wirklich Atari und die 2600er-Konsole in den Ruin getrieben. Ich meine, Atari ging dann auch später, also das Spielesektor von Atari, an Warner über. Atari konnte natürlich noch bestehen im Homecomputer-Bereich, aber spieletechnisch war die Marke leider eigentlich damit begraben.
Später haben sie ja noch mal versucht, eine Spielegruppe zu starten.
Ja, es gab den Jaguar, genau.
Aber das war ja alles der totale Fail. Aber in dem Moment haben dann die Japaner rechtzeitig übernommen und irgendwie das Feld dann auch erst mal bestellt.
Richtig, gerade als der Jaguar draußen war, da war natürlich Sony mit ihrer Playstation eigentlich der Leader.
Und Sega.
Und Nintendo sowieso mit dem ganzen Entertainment-System.
Und dann war es vorbei. Und in Deutschland sind dann diese Arcade-Spiele auch verboten worden.
Ja, das ist eigentlich brutal, wenn man sich das überlegt. 1985 hat sich die Bundesregierung tatsächlich entschlossen, Arcade-Maschinen aus der Öffentlichkeit zu verbannen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich die Jugendlichen das heute noch vorstellen können. Als die Arcade-Maschinen kamen, so Ende der 70er Jahre, da war es ja in dem Medial gesehen ziemlich karge Zeit. Man hatte einen Fernseher, wenn man Glück hatte, war der farbig. Viele hatten noch einen schwarz-weiß Fernseher. Da liefen ein, zwei, drei Programme drauf. Wenn man Glück hatte, vielleicht noch ein viertes. Die Sender strahlten erst ab 17 Uhr aus.
Es gab Senderschluss.
Ja, es gab Senderschluss, so um 24 Uhr oder.
Das soll jetzt wieder eingeführt werden im Internet.
Ja, so Medien-Junkies wie wir, sag ich mal, das war eine unwahrscheinlich karge Zeit. In der Zeit crashten plötzlich die Arcade-Automaten rein. Das war ja dann so faszinierend, dass man so ein interaktives Medium hatte.
Das war eigentlich die direkte Verbindung zur Zukunft. Und kostete irgendwie nur 10 Pfennig.
Eine Mark. Ein Automat kostete immer eine Mark.
Ich wollte jetzt noch den Mythos der Penny-Arcade aufrechterhalten. Das stimmt schon. Es war in der Regel dann doch mehr Geld, was man da reinwerfen musste.
Das war auch der Grund, warum die verboten wurden. Denn die Bundesregierung sagte, diese Spiele machen es süchtig. Und die ziehen den Jugendlichen Geld aus der Tasche.
Wir müssen auch unsere Jugend schützen.
Wir müssen auch unsere Jugend schützen. So wie wir es heute auch müssen mit irgendwelchen Netzsperren oder Kinderspielverboten.
Wo kommen wir denn dahin, wenn die Kinder alle spielen? Kinder sind doch nicht zum Spielen da.
Unglaublich, wenn man sich eigentlich überlegt. Früher zahlte man einmalig für ein Spiel. Also umgerechnet heute 50 Cent. Das ist natürlich viel Geld für einmal spielen, was vielleicht nur ein, zwei maximal fünf Minuten dauert. Oder wenn man gut ist, zehn Minuten. Wenn man es aber auf heutige Verhältnisse umrechnet, was zahlt man für ein Konsolenspiel? Wie ein Xbox oder PS3-Spieler zahlen wir 50 bis 60 Euro. Für dieses Geld hätte ich damals 100, 120 Mal am Automaten spielen können. Das klingt jetzt zwar nicht viel, aber das war schon viel. Weil so viel Zeit verbrachte man eigentlich auch nicht am Automaten. Es gibt wenige Automaten, die ich vielleicht über 50 oder 60 Mal tatsächlich dann auch gespielt habe. Also die Gründe, die damals im Vordergrund standen, natürlich kann man ein Automat süchtig machen oder ein Spiel süchtig machen, ein World of Warcraft kann heute auch süchtig machen und jedes Computerspiel kann auch süchtig machen. Aber die Tatsache ist dann aus der Öffentlichkeit tatsächlich zu verbannen. Es ging ja nicht darum, irgendwie die Jugend ein bisschen davor zu schützen oder es schwieriger zu machen. Sondern man wollte einfach diese ekligen Videospiele, die hatten ja keine Lobby, die wollten man einfach weghaben. Und hat sie dann in Spielhallen verbannt, die ab 18 waren.
Wo dann auch noch die Geldspielautomaten laufen.
Wo dann auch noch die Geldspielautomaten laufen. Und ich will nicht sagen, dass da jetzt irgendwie dubiose Leute da ständig in solchen Spielhallen waren. Aber als Jugendlicher oder so wollte man nicht in eine Spielhalle. Da wollte man in seinem Eiskaffee sein, sich mit seinen Kumpels treffen und dann am Automaten zocken. Man wollte nicht extra in eine Spielhalle gehen.
Es hat auch so eine Äquivalenz zum Musikbox eigentlich gewesen. So halt die Entertainment-Maschine. Die will man da haben, wo man Spaß hat.
Und es war ein extremer Angriff.
Aber es ist auch schön zu sehen, dass die Regierung sich rum und so jugendlich im Kommat hat, oder?
Ja, aber es hat echt vieles in Deutschland zerstört. Also in anderen Ländern ist es heute noch üblich, dass man in Arcade-Hallen geht, oder dass man irgendwo in Arcade-Automaten stehen hat. Das hat auch diese ganze Gaming-Szene, das hat bis heute noch, finde ich, Auswirkungen in Deutschland. Also wenn man sagt, man interessiert sich für Games, oder man interessiert sich für Spiele oder so, dann wird man von vielen ein bisschen schräg angesehen. Es hat noch kein gutes Standing, Games in Deutschland. Und dabei ist es doch die Essenz. Eine der essentiellen Dinge im Leben. Spielen. Es geht ja nur ums Spielen. Jedes Kind braucht Spiele, um zu lernen. Spielen heißt ja auch lernen. Spielen heißt ja auch kommunizieren. Spielen heißt ja auch, sozial miteinander umzugehen. Weil man ja auch während des Spiels kommuniziert. Auch bei Arcade-Spielen kommuniziert man. Wenn es Multiplayer-Spiele sind, ist es ja nicht nur, dass man schon so ein bisschen der Jugend trifft.
Man stand halt um diese Büze herum. Und so hat man sich dann irgendwie zusammengescharrt.
Man sagte nicht, wir treffen uns nicht unter Führung. Sondern man sagte, wir treffen uns am Pac-Man-Automaten. Und da wusste jeder Bescheid.
Bei mir war es dann später der C64 in der Kaufhaus-Abteilung.
Oder so.
Da hat man dann so seine Pier gehobt.
Dann bist du auch einer derjenigen, die nicht in die Schule ging, sondern zum C64.
Nee, in der Schule war ich dann schon. Doch, aber nach der Schule war ich definitiv erst mal bis 18 Uhr im Kaufhaus. Bis das dann zumachen musste. 18 Uhr.
Ja, das sieht man, was von der Faszination von diesen Geräten ausging.
Ja, es war unfassbar. Es war echt unfassbar. Ich muss zugebenen, meine guten Spieler habe ich gespielt und so. Und man hat so seine Vorlieben. Ich bin halt schnell beim Programmieren hängen geblieben. Aber es hat mich halt auch so ein bisschen dahin gebracht. Es war etwas, was mir auch gezeigt hat, die Universalität dieser Maschinen. Und es war natürlich auch ein direkter Ausdruck des Spaßes, den man damit haben konnte, sehr konkreter. Und ich meine, da wo Spiele entstehen, da ist Kultur. Das kann man einfach, glaube ich, mal so festhalten. Also Videospiele, Kultur, da muss man gar kein Fragezeichen dahinter packen. Weil es Spiele bringt, ist es einfach ein kulturelles Ereignis, Errungenschaft, was auch immer. Wenn man jetzt diese Arcade-Maschinen sich wieder ins Haus holen will, dann gibt es ja dann doch diverse Ressourcen. Was ja sehr populär ist, ist ja diese Mame-Geschichte. Wofür steht es nochmal gleich?
Multi-Arcade-Maschinen-Emulator.
Genau.
Das kam so in den 90ern, glaube ich, auf.
Ja, für unterschiedliche Plattformen dann auch.
Wer noch nicht weiß, wovon wir reden. Sozusagen ein Emulator, der in der Lage war, nahezu alle Maschinen, die sozusagen per Mikroprozessor funktioniert haben, also die quasi durch Software in Betrieb genommen wurden, zu emulieren, sodass man eben auf seinem Computer das laufen lassen konnte. Und dann hatte man sozusagen diese alten Spiele. Und ich weiß noch, als das irgendwie losging, da war das auch so dieses, ach, diese alte Kram, das will doch eh keiner mehr spielen. Das hat nicht unbedingt jeder so gesagt, aber ich glaube, manche haben es auch irgendwie so gedacht, wozu sollte man denn diesen alten Kram spielen? Wir haben doch schon so viele neue Spiele. Und die sind ja viel toller und höher und weiterer und haben mehr Auflösungen und 3D und nicht wahr? Und Sound und was nicht alles. Trotzdem, äh, ertappte man sich dann sozusagen sofort dabei, dass man so ein altes Game lädt und einen Höllen Spaß hat an diesem Minimalismus, über den wir schon gesprochen haben. Vielleicht noch mal kurz diese Mame-Sache an sich. Wie umfangreich ist denn dieser Emulator? Also kriegt man wirklich alles, was jemals in so einem Gerät gebaut wurde, emuliert heutzutage?
Also spieltechnisch bekommt man das schon emuliert. Das heißt, es gibt unzählige Spiele für Mame. Und die emulieren ja nicht nur Arcade-Maschinen, sondern die emulieren ja auch Konsolen oder so. Da sind ja auch Neo Geo-Spiele oder sowas dabei als Beispiel. Technisch bekommt man die alle auf den Schirm. Aber das eigentliche Feeling hat man nur am Automaten, ganz klar. Allein schon wegen dem Controller, wegen dem besonderen Controller. Ein Sea-Wolf zum Beispiel, ein Automat, wo man einen U-Boot-Kommandanten spielt, der mit Torpedos Schiffe abschießen muss.
Ach, den Periskop.
Genau, der hat einen Periskop. Da muss man durchs Periskop gucken. Und da muss man das Periskop bewegen. Und damit ändert sich auch die Blickrichtung auf dem Schirm. Sessen würde am PC gar keinen Spaß machen. Das ist wie, wenn man ein besseres Flash-Spiel spielt.
Also, wenn man holt sich so ein USB-Periskop.
Danke für den Tipp.
Das ist ja ein schönes User-Interface für wie nach links und rechts gucken. Kann man ja mit seiner Außenkamera seines Hauses motorgesteuert irgendwie verbinden. Dann guckt man so durch das Periskop und schaut aus seinem Haus raus.
Dann könnte man doch perfekt auf dem iPhone mit dem Gyroskop umsetzen. Das stimmt. Weil ich gerade iPhone erwähne. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich finde das iPhone ist so, da wird es jetzt vielleicht einen Aufschrei geben, aber ich würde sagen, so ein bisschen der Nachfolger der Arcade.
Aha, warum das?
Ganz subjektive Meinung, weil ich finde, dass dieses schnelle Spielerlebnis, was einem auch eine Arcade bietet und die Komprimierung auf die Spielidee gerade über das iPhone wieder auflebt. In der ganzen Zeit, wo Grafik und Power und Simulation und alles im Vordergrund stand, kommen jetzt wieder einfache Spielideen nach vorne. Es kommen wieder einfache Spielideen nach vorne. So ein Doodle Jump oder so, das ist im Prinzip so ein legitimer Nachfolger, wie ich finde, von einem alten Arcadespiel. Weil da das Spielprinzip im Vordergrund steht. Und auch dieses kurze Vergnügen. Ich meine, wann packt man sein iPhone raus, um zu spielen? Für ein kurzes Spielerlebnis. So wie man an einem Arcade-Automaten ging, eine Mic einwarf und auch ein kurzes Spielerlebnis haben wollte.
Da ist was dran, ich überlege, was ich sozusagen auf dem iPhone gerne spiele und es stimmt. Das sind wirklich diese super einfachen Games. Die natürlich jetzt auch nochmal so ein extra Feeling mit reinbringen, eben durch diese Touch-Bedienung. Das hatte man ja so bisher noch gar nicht. Aber es ist ja eigentlich auch sehr limitiert wiederum. Weil man muss halt da ein bisschen was machen. Da kann man so Seile durchschneiden, da fällt irgendwas runter, man kann irgendwo drauf tippen und so weiter. Beziehungsweise natürlich auch so die Steuerung durch das iPhone selber, durch die Bewegung. Ja, da ist was dran. Vielleicht ist das jetzt sozusagen auch wieder so ein Zyklus, dass man jetzt so eine Neubesinnung hat.
Und das Spiel muss einem ja auch sofort packen, sonst hat es auch keinen Erfolg, auch nicht auf dem iPhone. Ich meine, es haben nur die Spiele auf dem iPhone Erfolg, die auch tatsächlich...
Ist auch preislich sozusagen wieder in diesem Ein-Mark-Bereich. Man kauft es vielleicht so für 3 Euro, und dann spielt man es irgendwie 6 Mal. Da sind wir wieder genau bei diesen 50-Fennig, die wir schon damals hatten. Aber jetzt noch mal zu dem Mame. Was ich ja häufig gesehen habe, das muss ich jetzt schon deshalb sagen, weil unter anderem gab es ja auch einen im CCC. In Berlin gibt es noch so etwas. Ich weiß, es gibt viele Leute, die das mittlerweile gebaut haben. Die nehmen sich halt einfach einen PC, suchen sich so eine alte Konsolen-Maschine, so einen Arcade-Automaten. Wo kriegt man ja immer einen her.
Oder bauen das Gehäuse sogar selbst.
Oder bauen sich noch eins selber. Und bauen sich dann sozusagen so einen Bildschirm rein, Mame, und dann haben sie quasi so eine Mame-Station, wo sie alle möglichen Spiele spielen. Das ist auch schon mal ein Ansatz, oder? Ich meine, man hat so das Problem mit den Controllern, aber das lässt sich ja auch generalisieren. So Joysticks haben ja die meisten, und Knappe gibt es genug.
Ich habe so ein zwielständiges Verhältnis zum Mame. Gut, ich habe auch die Möglichkeit, an den originalen Arcade-Automaten zu spielen. Wenn ich das nicht hätte, dann würde ich auch eher auf die Mame zurückgreifen. Ich selber benutze als Mame, um gewisse Dinge in einem Spiel nachzuschauen, oder was zu probieren. Aber wenn ich das Spiel richtig erleben möchte, dann muss ich einfach an den Automaten gehen.
Die ganzen Spiele, die wir jetzt erwähnt haben, da kann man sagen, das war ja so toll. Aber wenn man nach dem Podcast das gerne mal nacherleben möchte, dann ist der schnellste Weg, über diesen Emulator zu gehen. Da hat man natürlich diese ROM-Problematik.
Die sind nämlich nicht offiziell letztendlich.
Genau, da ist ja immer noch Copyright. Am Anfang, als der Mame so aufkam, da lagen die ROMs auf 1000 Webseiten rum. Bis dann irgendwann mal die Hersteller auch begriffen haben, oh holla, unser alter Scheiß, der ist ja sogar noch was wert. Die Leute wollen das irgendwie sogar tatsächlich noch spielen. Weil es hat ja dann auch gerade in frühen Mobiltelefonen, da sind wir sozusagen auch sogar noch weit vor dem iPhone, haben ja diese ganzen Klassiker eigentlich auch wieder Einzug gehalten, eben durch die beschränkten Möglichkeiten. Was weiß ich, Tetris etc. Das waren Snake und so, also super einfache Sachen.
Woher kennen die jugendlichen Space Invaders oder Pac-Men oder Frogger? Von ihrem Handy. Die haben früher nie an einem Automaten gespielt, aber die kennen die Spiele trotzdem, weil sie es auf ihren Handys hatten.
Das stimmt. Frogger, oh Gott. Das ist auch schon wieder so eine Melodie, die man nicht aus dem Kopf rauskriegt. Hörst du sie auch?
Ich summ sie jetzt aber nicht.
In der DDR gab es doch auch eine Arcade-Maschine.
In der DDR gab es eine einzige Arcade-Maschine.
Eine einzige?
Das war das sogenannte Poly-Play. Der hieß Poly, weil darin mehr Spiele enthalten waren. Es war zwar ein dedicated Automat, den gab es nur einmal in der Form, aber der enthielt so acht bis zehn Spiele, je nach Bestückung.
Das heißt, ausgerechnet die DDR ist so ökonomisch da rangegangen, wie sie das die Spielhallenbetreiber erst später eingefordert haben?
Ja, die DDR ist erst 1986 zur Arcade-Kultur gestoßen.
Ach so, von 86 ist der?
Ja, der ist von 86 und die technische Basis ist auch ein 8-Bit-Prozessor. Ein Z80-Klon heißt dann U-880. Ja und mit so einem einfachen 8-Bits-Prozessor kann man halt nicht so viel reißen oder?
Was für Games sind da drauf gewesen?
Da sind so Games drauf wie Hase und Wolf als Beispiel, so ein Pac-Man-Klon oder so ein Pac-Man-Ableger. Aber wenn man das vergleicht mit dem original Pac-Man, der sechs Jahre früher erschien, kann man nicht vergleichen. Also der Polyplay hatte zum Beispiel nur acht Farben. Das sind eher Spiele, die muten an wie in der frühen Pong-Ära. Die haben so simple Grafik. Es ist wie ein Gunfight aus 1975 oder so, dieses Hirschjagd, was es da drauf gibt. Also man kann es überhaupt nicht mit westlichen Automaten von 1900.
Abfahrtslauf, Schmetterlinge, Schießboden, Autorennen, Merkspiel, Wasserrohrbruch.
Richtig.
Das Autorennen war dann auch wie das Grandtruck.
Ja und wann kam Grandtruck 10? Das war 74. Da lagen 16 Jahre dazwischen.
Ja unwesentlich, aber Pong gab es keins oder wie?
Also nicht, dass die Spiele keinen Spaß machen.
Ich habe irgendwas gehört davon, dass es auch ein Pong gab. Ich glaube, es gab einen Ort in Berlin, wo es ein Pong gab. Keine Ahnung, die haben sich vielleicht aus dem Westen geklaut.
Ja, oder selbst gebaut. Obwohl es gab ja eine Ostkonsole auch und da lief ja ein Pong drauf. Kann vielleicht sein, dass daraus auch Automaten gebaut wurden. Das ist gut möglich, das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Aber sehr hübsch mit dem braunen Holzgehäuse und so, das hätte auch super mit Mutters Wandschrank gepasst.
Auch einer unserer Schmuckstücke in der Ausstellung, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Die Spiele machen auch Spaß, wie auch alle alten Spiele Spaß machen, egal ob limitierte Technik oder nicht. Der Automat ist inzwischen extrem selten nach der Wende. Also 2000 Automaten wurden hergestellt und zwei Hände voll von Automaten sind auf der Welt noch registriert oder bekannt. Wir haben hier allein zwei in unserer Ausstellung.
Also ihr habt schon eine sehr wertvolle Sammlung hier, kann man sagen. Also kulturell wertvoll, meine ich jetzt.
Kulturell wertvoll auf alle Fälle. Der tatsächliche Wert, ja klar, so ein Adams Family Flipper oder was, der hat sicherlich einen Wert von 2.000 bis 3.000 Euro. Aber bei den Automaten, da schwankt das erheblich. Es kommt immer drauf an, wie viel jemand zahlen möchte. Also wenn man zum Beispiel auf Ebay schaut, was so ein Automat wert ist, da hat man überhaupt keinen Anhaltspunkt, weil ein Automat schwer ist, den kann man nicht verschicken. Der wird immer nur gegen Abholungen gehandelt. Da gehen als Automaten weg für 10 oder 20 Euro. Es ist unglaublich, wenn man überhaupt noch Arcade-Automaten angeboten bekommt. Aber wenn einer ein Sammler ist und der sucht einen speziellen Automaten und der ist sehr selten oder hat eine spezielle Platine oder eine seltene Platine, dann kann ein Automat auch gerne mal 3.000 oder 5.000 Euro wert sein.
Seid ihr immer noch auf der Suche nach neuen?
Ja, immer, ständig. Also wenn ich auch die Gelegenheit habe, auch einen Aufruf zu starten. Also wenn ihr Automaten für uns habt, dann...
Also bevorzugt noch voll funktionsfähige?
Nein, die alles mögliche. Also wir haben schon den Skill um die Automaten.
Die richtigen Spezies am Start.
Genau, wir haben ganz tolle Spezies, echt.
Grüße.
Die kriegen alles wieder zusammengeschraubt.
Genau, die kriegen alles wieder zusammengeschraubt.
Also insbesondere, falls jemand was Defektes hat, von dem man meinte, das wäre ja eh nur noch für den Schrott.
Ja, das denken viele. Für die ist es einfach nur ein Wandschrank, der rumsteht, wo sie denken, ich nehme nur Platz weg und dann schmeiße ich weg. Bitte nicht, meldet euch bei uns. RetroGames.info ist unsere Seite.
Ist aber schon ganz schön voll hier, ne? Passt ja nicht mehr so viel rein.
Ja, wir könnten auch irgendwie einen neuen Platz haben oder Unterstützung in jeder Form können wir gebrauchen. Also ob finanzieller Natur, Sponsoren oder einfach einen neuen Platz in Karlsruhe, den wir ein bisschen günstiger vielleicht bekommen oder den wir gesponsert bekommen.
Wie viel Quadratmeter braucht ihr denn so? Was habt ihr hier?
Im Moment haben wir so 250 Quadratmeter.
Könnte mehr sein.
Ach, könnte viel, viel mehr sein.
Und irgendwelche Pläne, das auch mal in so eine reguläre Ausstellung zu überführen?
Also unsere Arcade-Ausstellung ist schon eine reguläre Ausstellung in dem Sinn. Also wir haben zwar nur zweimal in der Woche geöffnet, wir würden aber gerne eine reguläre Ausstellung in der Form machen, dass wir halt noch mehr Konsolen und mehr Homecomputer aufnehmen, damit wir das Thema Videospiele an sich, wir sehen uns jetzt nicht nur als Arcade-Halle, sondern wir wollen ja die Videospielkultur erhalten und fördern. Wir möchten das ganze Spektrum abdecken und dazu brauchen wir einfach mehr Platz, denn die Regale, die du da hinten siehst, die sind voller Konsolen und voller Homecomputer. Also wir haben echt fast alles am Stadt, was so verfügbar ist. Wir haben aber noch nicht den Platz, das auszustellen.
Ja, und die haben zweimal pro Woche offen, das heißt, wenn man jetzt sozusagen ein bisschen Blut geleckt hat und sich denkt, mal gucken, wie das damals Anfang der 80er-Jahre denn so wirklich war und was der Unterschied ist zwischen Mame laufen lassen und mal richtig anfassen, könnte man hier einfach aufschlagen.
Genau, Dienstagsabends haben wir offen ab 20 Uhr, das ist unser Mitgliederabend, sind aber Gäste immer, herzlich willkommen. Und Samstags ab 21 Uhr, da findet die sogenannte Freeplay-Party statt.
Dann kann man hier auch losdateln.
Dann kann man hier losdateln bis Open End, sage ich mal, das geht dann also bis 4 oder 5 Uhr nachts. Und da ist dann auch richtig Party und wir legen noch 80er-Platten auf, richtig Vinyl und das steht auch alles unter dem Motto 80er.
Genau, wenn ihr kommt, dann bitte aber auch schlecht kleiden, weil das gehört zu den 80ern auch dazu. Ich muss sagen, das ist schon eine geile Atmo da hinten, mit diesen ganzen Maschinen. Als ich da irgendwie drin stand und irgendwie den Strom dazugeschaltet hast und auf einmal alle diese Maschinen hochfuhren und irgendwie ihre merkwürdigen Geräusche von sich gaben, dann kam man sich schon so ein bisschen vor wie in so einem 80er-Jahre-Horror-Movie. Auf einmal geht der Strom von alleine an und so.
Du bist noch geiler, wenn du sie ausschaltest und plötzlich ist es still.
Das ist noch ein Mehrhorror-Movie zwischen den Autobahnen.
Ja, Mario, haben wir es.
Ach, wir haben so viel vergessen eigentlich und so viel noch nicht erwähnt, aber wie das aber so ist, können wir nicht.
Man kann nicht alles erzählen. Aber wer Lust hat, kann sich das hier alles erzählen lassen. Bei Retro Games in Karlsruhe.
Genau, kann ja auch mal auf unserer Seite schauen. Das sind auch einige Automaten, die wir in der Ausstellung haben, in Form von einem kleinen virtuellen Katalog beschrieben. Für alle Interessierten kann ich einfach nur empfehlen. Im Netz gibt es ganz tolle Seiten, zum Beispiel die Killer List of Video Games, die clof.com, K-L-O-V, Killer List of Video Games. Das sind eigentlich alle Arcade-Automaten der Welt beschrieben. Das ist die zentrale Datenbank für Arcade-Automaten oder Videospiele im Allgemeinen. Wer sich für Pinballs interessiert, das sei die IPDB erwähnt, die International Pinball Database, ipdb.org. Wer sich noch mehr in das Thema einarbeiten möchte, den kann ich auch noch zwei Bücher empfehlen. Das ist eine rein subjektive Meinung, aber ich finde zum Beispiel Arcade Fever von John Sellers sehr gut. Das ist ein sehr kostengünstiges Buch. Es kostet, glaube ich, so 14, 15 Dollar. Das umfasst diese Goldene Ära, also die Zeit der Goldenen Ära beschreibt das. Das Buch ist sehr witzig geschrieben. Es ist kein direktes Nachschlagewerk, wo bis auf jedes Detail in den Automaten eingegangen wird. Aber man bekommt einen perfekten Überblick über die ganze Arcade-Kultur. Und wer sich ein bisschen mehr einarbeiten möchte in das Thema, dem empfehle ich das Buch Super Arcade von Van Burnham. Das ist eine Frau, die es witzigerweise geschrieben hat. Also Arcade-Kultur verbindet man jetzt nicht unbedingt mit Frauen. Also es ist mehr so eine Männergeschichte. Und das beschreibt das Thema oder die Arcade-Automaten noch genauer und hat auch super Bilder. Also ein bisschen teurer, weil es ein richtig großes, dickes, schweres Bildband ist.
Ja, super Mario, super Mario.
Dann sag ich mal, meine Eltern wissen warum sie mich Mario nennen.
Sehr passend, das wissen wir jetzt auch gerade erst klar. Ja, vielen Dank für den Überblick über Arcade-Games.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Ja, mir auch. Und ich hoffe auch, ihr allen beim Zuhören. Ihr wisst schon, wenn ihr mal hier daddeln wollt, hier klingeln ordentlich die Automaten. Ja, auch dieser Terminator-Flipper, für Flipper habe ich ja auch noch was über, aber das muss man noch in eine andere Sendung packen.
Das passt durch die eigene Sendung, ja.
Okay, aber jetzt ist Schluss und ich sage Tschüss und bis bald bei Chaos Radio Express. Auf Wiedersehen!